Hey guys, listen, I'm super high energy. I'm high energy. I think I'm high energy. I'm probably the highest I've ever been. I just got a call from the high energy. I shot the coffee into the back of my knee. I'm on fire right now. I just pulled my car here.
嘿，各位，听着，我精力超级充沛。我精力充沛。我觉得我精力充沛。我可能是有生以来精力最旺盛的一次。我刚接到一个精力充沛的电话。我把咖啡注射到我膝盖后面了。我现在斗志昂扬。我刚把车停在这。
I didn't even have time to let it drive. I need to turn it on. I just had two pints of hog and does. Hang on, guys. Let's make sure we get this episode started. We still got the gas. Ready? Here comes. We're going to set it I'm going to start. Wait, are you retiring from smartness? No, no, no, no, that's, that's, that's, that's, I'm not, wait, why are you?
我甚至都没时间让它熄火。我得把它打开。我刚才吃了两品脱哈根达斯。等等，伙计们。让我们确保这期节目顺利开始。我们油箱里还有油。准备好了吗？来啦。我们要把它设为——我要开始了。等等，你要从聪明界退休了吗？不不不不不，那是，那是，那是，我没有，等等，你为什么？
Well, we do have a very great replacement waiting whenever you're ready to. It can, doesn't have to be now, it can be next year or whenever. I feel like it's sideswiped. I got it. I just want to give them a heads up. I want to, oh, you are not retiring. You're not retiring. Okay, no.
好吧，无论你什么时候准备好，我们确实有一个非常棒的接替人选在等着。可以，不一定非得是现在，可以是明年或者什么时候。我觉得我被侧面撞了一下。我懂了。我只是想给他们提个醒。我想，哦，你没有退休。你没有退休。好吧，不。
What I was going to say was Jesus. Sorry. How excited we are for Shiny winning the Tony. Oh, well, there's that. I mean, Sean Hayes. Yes, Sean Hayes won a fucking Tony. Oh, well, there's that. I mean, Sean Hays. Yes. You want to fucking Tony. Tony. Best actor for Good Night Oscar. I I know it's so funny. Very nice. Remember when remember when you said you were going to go do this play in Chicago, an idea that you had. you got this great writer and gosh, you're
我本来想说的是，天哪。对不起。我们为香奈儿赢得托尼奖感到多么兴奋。哦，好吧，还有那回事。我是说，肖恩·海斯。是的，肖恩·海斯他妈的赢得了一个托尼奖。哦，好吧，还有那回事。我是说，肖恩·海斯。是的。你他妈的赢得了托尼奖。托尼奖。凭借《晚安，奥斯卡》获得最佳男主角。我——我知道太搞笑了。非常好。还记得当——还记得当你说你要去芝加哥演这出戏的时候，那是你的一个想法。你找到了这个伟大的作家，天哪，你
scared and you don't know how it's going to go. Doug what's his name? Well, and you got great reviews and there was a possibility of it going to Broadway. You weren't sure. Do you remember you were in Scotty, where in that shitty apartment in Chicago right above the, the, the, the, the fire station? Yeah. Yeah.
很害怕，你不知道进展会怎样。道格，叫什么来着？好吧，你获得了极好的评价，而且还有去百老汇演出的可能。你当时很不确定。你还记得你在斯科蒂吗，在芝加哥那个破公寓里，就在那个——那个——那个——那个——那个消防局楼上？对。对。
Please take my word. Got such a deal on it. And then you go to Broadway and you're not quick name of the theater Jason name of the theater best go the spicy And then and then you and then you do a great job that you get great reviews and then like don't talk about Tony nominations Which is a jinx it and you got a nomination unbelievable. He's ever going to win, right? They can't give Johnny a ton of, they give him the, they give him the drama desk and the outer circles, but in the Tony's not going to get a man.
请相信我。租得太划算了。然后你去了百老汇，你不是——剧院叫什么名字，杰森？剧院叫什么名字？最好去——太辣了。然后——然后——然后你表现得很棒，获得了超高的评价，然后就像——别谈论托尼奖提名，因为这会带来厄运，而你居然得到了提名，真是难以置信。他永远不会获奖，对吧？他们不可能给强尼一个托尼奖，他们给了他戏剧桌奖和外剧评人圈奖，但在托尼奖上他绝对拿不到奖，老兄。
You got it. But there yours is spelled with an I, right? And it's dotted with a heart, right? I mean, it's like more of a Tony, a little bit of an award. The Tony, Tony, Tony's, Tony's, Tony's done it again. But no, that's very more of a 2020 than an award. The 2020, 2020. The 2020 is done it again. But no, that's very kind of. I think congrats, man.
你懂的。但你的名字里拼写带个“i”，对吧？上面还点着一颗心，对吧？我的意思是，这更像是一个托尼奖，带点奖项的感觉。托尼，托尼，托尼奖，托尼，托尼又得奖了。不过不，这更像2020年的感觉，而不是一个奖项。2020，2020。2020年又得奖了。不过不，这真是太……我想恭喜你，老兄。
That's very sweet. You guys already have showered me with so much love and praise in our texts and things. So, but thank you. And it is wild. It's wild to Jason what you just said about doing, you know, the week we shot that document, or the two weeks we shot that
这太贴心了。你们在短信和其他东西里已经用这么多的爱和赞美把我淹没了。所以，不过谢谢你们。这真是太疯狂了。杰森，你刚才说的话太疯狂了，关于我们拍那部纪录片的那周，或者我们拍那部
doc series that's now wearing, I was trying to remember. We always see that by the way, if somebody wanted to see that, if somebody wants to do that, where would they go? It would be a max. It's max. Oh, max. That's where they find it. Sean, not only are you learning, you're, we, we, we arrived, we did those shows on the
现在在播出的纪录片系列的四周，我刚才在想。顺便说一句，我们总是这么说，如果有人想看那个，如果有人想看，他们去哪儿看？会在Max上。是Max。哦，Max。他们在那里找到它。肖恩，你不仅在学习，我们——我们——我们到了，我们在那个
weekend and the next day you flew to Chicago. That's right. And the next day flew to Chicago to do it, just to the last show. But Jay, you were sleeping or something and I had to wheel to run lines with me. Yeah. No, really.
周末演出了，第二天你就飞去了芝加哥。没错。第二天就飞去芝加哥演出，就赶最后一场演出。但是，杰森，你当时在睡觉还是怎么的，我不得不跟——对对手台词。对。真的假的。
And Will ran lines with me on the couch and I was like, yeah. It was that that's so bizarre to me. That's why they got the special, you got a certificate. I'm on the Tony, yeah, the engraved just a little spot. It just look underneath it. It says rail lines with it says.
而且威尔在沙发上跟我对台词，我当时就想，是的。那——那对我来说太离奇了。这就是为什么他们给了你特别奖，你得到了一个证书。我在托尼奖上，对，那个刻字的小地方。你只要看看它下面。上面写着，对台词的地点，写着。
Will's. Will get into it. But we just could not be prouder. And the fact that we've both seen it and can attest to its quality is is also well. And I you know, you get so nervous when you get up there and you receive an award and you forget to thank people and I really honestly forgot to thank to my best friends in the whole world. You guys oh wait. Why? And that would go on here and my family too. I thought I was actually taken by how together you were up there with
威尔的。威尔，深入讲讲吧。但我们简直不能再骄傲了。而且我们俩都看过并且能证明它的品质，这也——而且，你知道，当你上台领奖时，你会非常紧张，以至于忘记感谢别人，我真的，老实说，忘记感谢我全世界最好的两个朋友了。你们，哦，等等。为什么？这也适用于这里，还有我的家人。实际上，我被你在台上时表现得那么镇定给迷住了
that. I was like, Rick, how was your name? I was a red double actor because you seemed not nervous at all. I love when you said Scotty. It's Scotty, right? And you were so funny. So, Sean, and the only the only one one liner I had ready should I had won was, uh, this is going to be the first time I'm going to ask her when a Tony.
我当时想，里克，你叫什么名字？我是一个双重演员，因为你看上去一点也不紧张。我喜欢你刚才说斯科蒂的时候。是斯科蒂，对吧？你太搞笑了。所以，肖恩，我准备好的唯一一个单口包袱，假如我赢了的话，就是：“这是我第一次让一个女人赢得托尼奖。”
Yeah. And in the room there, eh, didn't land so well. It was like, I TV played great. So who cares about the room, right? But, but um, the right. Listen, I was watching, I was watching that thing and I was just thinking, you see all these theater people in there and they got there in the biggest night and I thought, man, this is show-based for losers.
对。然后在屋里，呃，反响不是很好。就像，呃，电视播出效果棒极了。所以谁在乎屋里的反应呢，对吧？但是，但是……对。听着，我当时在看，我当时在看那个节目，我只是在想，你看到里面所有的戏剧界人士，他们在那里的那个最重要的夜晚，我想，天啊，这真是失败者的演艺圈。
You know? That's Will texted that. Will was texting me in real time while he was watching the Tony Awards saying, this is the first time I've ever watched the Tony Awards because of you. And you put it on. Better than when.
你知道吗？那是威尔发短信说的。威尔在观看托尼奖颁奖典礼时实时给我发短信说：“这是我因为你第一次看托尼奖。”而且你把它放出来了。比……的时候还要好。
Better than when. But it was wild. You know, it's that also when they call your name, it's that weird thing where you watch TV your whole life, whether it's Oscars, Emmy's, Tony's, whatever, and you watch other people walk up there. And you're like, oh, that's so nice. I'm a big fan or I love that show
比……的时候还要好。但那真是太疯狂了。你知道，当他们念到你的名字时，也是那种奇怪的感觉，你一辈子都在看电视，不管是奥斯卡、艾美奖、托尼奖还是别的什么，你看着其他人走上台。然后你会想，哦，那太好了。我是个大粉丝，或者我好喜欢那个节目
or that whatever, that actor. And then when you're, while I was walking up the steps, it was like, I'm not supposed to be walk. Like other people walk up the steps. That's supposed to be you. Didn't get you know. Didn't you get you to that walk with the, what is it? Half a dozen Emmys you've won.
或者是那个什么的，那个演员。然后当你——当我走上台阶时，就好像，我本不应该走——就像其他人走上台阶那样。那应该是你。你难道没有——难道你没有用那种步伐走过吗，是什么来着？你赢得了半打艾美奖。
I have one. Gold and Globes, Sag Awards, all these other things. I was just thinking, I was just thinking between us, between us, we've won a handful of golden globes and Emmys and sags and Tony. I mean, that's amazing. Isn't that what we did in the past? We did. It would be an egot group.
我有一个。金球奖、演员工会奖，所有这些其他的东西。我只是在想，我只是在想，在我们之间，在我们之间，我们赢得了一堆金球奖、艾美奖、演员工会奖和托尼奖。我的意思是，这太惊人了。难道这就是我们过去做的事吗？我们做过。那将是一个EGOT俱乐部。
No, but between the three of us, we've won all these, I mean, I haven't won any of them, but you guys, and then I, but between the three of us, but you ran lines with both of us. I've run line with both of you guys, and you've both been one. So yeah, if you look at my thing, like, but, but between the three of us, but you ran lines with both of us. I've run line with both of you guys and you've both been one. So, yeah, I know, I really look at my thing. Like, yeah, technically I've never won an award, but you know, that's we won it. Hey, we all three won a webby. We did. We did. We did. How about a few of them?
不，但是在我们三个人之间，我们赢得了所有这些，我的意思是，我没有赢得过任何一个，但是你们，然后我，但是在我们三个人之间，但是你跟我们俩都对过台词。我跟你们俩都对过台词，而且你们俩都得过奖。所以，是的，如果你看我的东西，就像，但是，但是在我们三个人之间，但是你跟我们俩都对过台词。我跟你们俩都对过台词，而且你们俩都得过奖。所以，是的，我知道，我真的看我的东西。就像，是的，严格来说我从来没得过奖，但你知道，那是我们赢的。嘿，我们三个都赢得了威比奖。我们赢了。我们赢了。我们赢了。赢了好几个呢。
We did. A few of them. Guys, thank you so much for saying that truly. Truly. Thank you for all the love and support you've shown me and the show by talking about it on the podcast. And you guys are the best. I love you. We love you.
我们赢了。好几个呢。伙计们，非常感谢你们这么说，真的。真的。谢谢你们在播客中谈论它，向我和这个节目倾注了如此多的爱和支持。你们是最好的。我爱你们。我们爱你。
And anyway, we had to talk about it because it was just too important. And now we can get to our regular scheduled program, which is the Fantastic Jennifer Carter episode. Can't wait. Welcome to Smart episode. Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. That is very sweet, you guys.
不管怎样，我们不得不谈论它，因为它太重要了。现在我们可以进入我们的常规节目了，也就是非常精彩的詹妮弗·加纳那一集。迫不及待了。欢迎来到聪明榜样节目。欢迎来到《聪明人》。欢迎来到《聪明人》。欢迎来到《聪明人》。你们太贴心了，伙计们。
Thank you. Seannier, are you happy that we're on day two of your days off? Yes. This is your weekend right now. Monday Tuesday is your weekend. It is Monday Tuesday and my weekend. How's your eyeball? Have you been performing?
谢谢。肖尼，我们现在处于你休假的第一天，你高兴吗？高兴。这就是你的周末。周一周二是你的周末。现在确实是周一和周二，我的周末。你的眼珠怎么样？你一直在演出吗？
I don't know. I'm going to go back after we're done here. I'm going to go back and see if my retinus detached. Isn't that crazy? Yeah, but did he re-stick it last week? Well, I don't know. We talked about Vasevago, right? Where he gets sick and you faint.
我不知道。等我们这儿忙完，我要回去。我要回去看看我的视网膜有没有脱落。这不疯狂吗？是的，但他上周帮你重新粘好了吗？嗯，我不知道。我们聊过《瓦西瓦戈》，对吧？就是他生病然后昏倒的那部。
Yep. Yeah. He puts the anesthesia in your eye and then opens it and sticks something in your eye to keep it open. This is an eye doctor or just a fellow downstairs. It's a proctologist. This is the guy. And then he shoots lasers in your eye and it's kind of painful.
对。对。他在你眼睛里打麻药，然后把它撑开，往你眼里塞个东西来把它撑开。这是眼科医生还是楼下的伙计？是个直肠科医生。就是这家伙。然后他在你眼里打激光，这有点痛。
Like from the hip. Yeah, he shoots from the hip. Poo, pooo. Yeah, and he puts those star wars sounds in it to make me sooth like. He does, huh? Poo, poo, poo. Yeah, that guy's not Wars sounds in it to make me sooth. He does, huh? Pupu, pupu. Yeah, that guy's not an accredited doctor, Sean. But Sean, you've been, you've been doing the show, right?
就像从髋部开枪一样。对，他从髋部开枪。扑，扑。对，他在里面加入那些星球大战的声音，让我感觉舒缓一点。他加了，是吧？扑，扑，扑。对，那家伙不是——大战的声音，让我感觉舒缓。他加了，是吧？扑扑，扑扑。对，那家伙不是个有资质的医生，肖恩。但肖恩，你一直在——你一直在演这出戏，对吧？
Didn't you, what did you have like one day off or two days off with the, I have to the other thing? I have Monday's and Tuesday's off. No, no, but I mean, after you got your, your last week, yeah, you do. Yeah, I did the laser thing on Tuesday and had two shows the next day. You did seven shows after the laser thing. Yeah, I did laser thing on Tuesday and had two shows the next day. You did seven shows after the laser thing. Yeah, it was. Did you bump into any any any cast members or set decoration?
你不是——你做那个——上周你只有一天假还是两天假？我必须——另一件事。我周一和周二休息。不，不，我的意思是，在你做完——上周之后，是的，你做了。对，我周二做了激光手术，第二天有两场演出。你在做完激光手术后演了七场。对，我周二做了激光手术，第二天有两场演出。你在做完激光手术后演了七场。对，是的。你有撞到任何——任何——任何演员或布景道具吗？
No, no set decoration. No, I did okay, but I'm supposed to bang my head, you know, when I try to get those voices out of my head. So I cut back and I just grabbed my head now. That's good. Not as good. Not as good. Do you do you feel like it might be a nice kind of homage
没有，没有布景道具。我做得还行，但我本该撞到自己的头，你知道的，当我试图把那些声音从脑子里赶出去的时候。所以我减少了，现在我只是抓住我的头。那挺好。没那么好。没那么好。你觉得这会不会是一种很好的致敬方式呢？
if eventually you end up using your mom's eye? Well, no, I'm serious because I know that Tracy's got it, right? Trace. I could use that. Trace, get it shined up. I could get, I could finally see how my mom saw. No, you're not gonna have to do that. I think you're okay. Because you made it through last week.
如果最终你用上了你妈妈的眼睛？不，我是认真的，因为我知道特雷西有，对吧？特雷。我可以用那个。特雷，把它擦亮。我终于能看看我妈妈是怎么看的了。不，你不需要那样做。我觉得你没事。因为你上周挺过来了。
Well, we're gonna find, I know, I made it through. So we're gonna find out what happens today after we're done here, and then I'll let you guys know, because I'm sure you'll be on the edge of your seats. Hey, quick question, Jason. Are you wearing one of those, those sauna sweatsuits? Yeah, it looks like it. Are you trying to, are you trying to cut weight?
好吧，我们会发现的——我知道，我挺过来了。所以我们会看看今天这里忙完后会发生什么，然后我会让你们知道，因为我确信你们会拭目以待的。嘿，问个快问题，杰森。你穿着那种——那种桑拿发汗服吗？对，看起来像。你想——你想减重吗？
It's just a crappy overthrow. You have to look at the top. It's a little cloudy today. You know, speaking of Proctologist, guys, our next guest, wait, what? It's not my guest. Jamie, and you have the exact same glasses on today. And same hair.
这只是一件破旧的外套。你得看看上面。今天有点多云。说到直肠科医生，伙计们，我们的下一位嘉宾，等等，什么？这不是我的嘉宾。杰米，你今天戴着一模一样的眼镜。还有一样的发型。
We should start at the end. Well, the part yours in the middle. No, it's not meant to be in the middle. It really isn't. You know, I look like a water yak when it goes. Well, we've been through what it looks like in profile when it's just the outline. Yeah. On the smartless logo, I look like a dickhead. Yeah. A literal dickhead. But let's not. By the way, let's talk about our FaceTime last night. Well, for two seconds, FaceTime is on it? Was I on it?
我们应该从头开始。嗯，你的发缝在中间。不，它本来就不应该在中间。真的不是。你知道的，我看起来像一只正在移动的水牦牛。好吧，我们已经讨论过当它只是轮廓时侧面看起来是什么样了。对。在聪明榜样的标志上，我看起来像个白痴。对。一个名副其实的白痴。但我们别说了。顺便说一句，我们来谈谈昨晚的视频通话吧。好吧，就两秒钟，视频通话开着吗？我在里面吗？
No. And he, literally, never seen any human being eat this fast. He's talking, he's talking, he's talking while I'm talking to him. He's making a sandwich. Maybe 30 seconds later, the entire sandwich is gone. It's a ham and cheese sandwich gone like that. Was it a small size bread or something? No.
没有。而他，简直了，从没见过任何人吃得这么快。他在说话，他在说话，我在跟他说话的时候他还在说话。他在做一个三明治。大概30秒后，整个三明治就没了。一个火腿奶酪三明治就这样没了。是小号的面包还是什么的？没有。
It was a big, full size bread? Yeah, big sandwich. I just hammered it in like four bites. And then he went on a hike. I needed fuel to go on your hike. You know, and I went on a hike. Did you put on, did you strap on the heavy hands and the heavy ankles and walk up the hills?
是一个大号的全尺寸面包？对，大三明治。我只是四口就把它砸进肚子里了。然后他去徒步了。我需要补充能量去徒步。你知道的，我去徒步了。你有没有——你有没有绑上沉重的手部沙袋和脚踝沙袋，然后走山路？
Yeah, I wore the weight vest. And did you zip into the rubber suit? I wish. Do you ever talk on your hike while you zip into the rubber suit? Do you ever do you ever talk on your hike while you're on the phone? Do you ever pass anybody? Wait, what kind of question is that? Meaning like when you're walking and do you talk to people on your hike because I don't like it when people are like, so I'm I do sometimes what are you doing tonight? And I'm like just calm me when you're done. All the role calls, I'll roll call sometimes.
对，我穿着负重背心。那你有没有拉上橡胶衣的拉链？我希望有。你在徒步时会一边拉上橡胶衣拉链一边聊天吗？你在徒步时会一边打电话一边聊天吗？你有没有超越过任何人？等等，这是什么问题？意思是当你走路时，你会跟徒步时遇到的人聊天吗，因为我不喜欢别人说：“所以，我——我有时候会问，你今晚在干嘛？”而我会说：“等我忙完再打给我吧。”所有的点名，我有时会点名。
What if you got one of those, you know, they use them for motion capture where you get where the helmet with the camera that's looking back at you. You could do face times while you're walking. You could do face time. Yeah. But you know what I mean when people are like talking to you.
如果你有那种——你知道的，他们用于动作捕捉的那种，你戴着一个带有摄像头的头盔，摄像头正对着你的脸。你就可以在走路时进行视频通话了。你可以进行视频通话。对。但你知道我的意思，当别人跟你说话时——
I do, of course I do. I'm that guy. And what happens is also is that that street is, I will have, and you don't always look the best because it's quite straight uphill and you get quite tired. Jay, we've done it before together. And remember Amanda's mom used to do it every day.
我知道，我当然知道。我就是那种人。而且发生的情况是，那条街，我会有——而且你看起来并不总是最好，因为那是相当陡峭的上坡，而且你会相当累。杰森，我们以前一起走过。还记得阿曼达的妈妈以前每天都去吗？
And people go like, yeah, man, I saw you out there the other day. I'm like, thinking like, I just looked like a sweaty slob that was off and then puffed and I didn't know. I didn't know. And on a weekday. Actually, you saw me there a couple of weeks ago. You pulled over. Yeah.
人们会说：“嘿，伙计，我前几天在外面看到你了。”我心里想的是，我看起来就像个满头大汗的懒汉，上气不接下气，而我根本不知道。我不知道。而且还是在工作日。事实上，你几周前在那里看到过我。你把车停下了。对。
Yeah. But you pulled over. You didn't know it was me. You thought I was just a hot guy. Yeah. Walking up the hill. That's what you said. Hey, hot guy. And then you saw me.
对。但你把车停下了。你不知道是我。你以为我只是个辣哥。对。正走上山。你就是这么说的。嘿，辣哥。然后你看到了我。
What I mean? Ha ha. Hey, well, Hi, guy. Hi, guy. Instead of a guy. Hi, guy. Hi, guy.
我是什么意思？哈哈。嘿，好吧，嗨，伙计。嗨，伙计。而不是“一个家伙”。嗨，伙计。嗨，伙计。
Um, this, our guest is a really quick. Sorry. Yeah, go ahead. I guess our guest is a fun time. No, no, just really quick. One of the most embarrassing moments of my entire life, I was driving off the NBC lot. This is decades ago. And there was this really good looking guard. And I rolled out in front of my, I was in the car with me.
呃，这位，我们的嘉宾真的很——等等，抱歉。对，请继续。我想我们的嘉宾是一个有趣的人——不，不，只是非常快地插一句。我一生中最尴尬的时刻之一，我当时正把车开出NBC片场。那是几十年前的事了。有一个长得非常帅的警卫。我摇下车窗——当时车里还有我——
And I looked back just as I passed him, and I went like that. And the guard, I noticed the guards saw me do that. And all of him and the five other guards were laughing so hard because I knew it was me that checked him out. It was so embarrassed. That's my story. Oh, we always need something to cut.
就在我经过他的一瞬间，我回过头，我做了那个动作。然后那个警卫——我注意到警卫看到我做那个动作了。他和另外五个警卫笑得前仰后合，因为我知道是我去搭讪了他。太尴尬了。这就是我的故事。哦，我们总是需要删掉一些东西。
Will, if you're going to want to cut that. All the way there in no destination. I tell you, you never guess cut. Oh, great. Is our guest today? This person is not going to get, because you're going to want to see this. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful.
威尔，如果你打算把那段删掉的话。漫无目的地开着。我告诉你，你永远猜不到会被剪掉。哦，太棒了。今天的嘉宾是？这个人不会被放过，因为你会想看这个的。我要更小心一点。我要更小心一点。我要更小心一点。
I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I tell you, you never guess cut. Oh, great. Is our guest today? This person is not gonna get, because you're gonna wanna see this person, and the people who hire this person want this person to be in every frame of everything they do. Because this is somebody who's been in many frames for many years. This is a person who's done, it really run the gamut.
我要更小心一点。我要更小心一点。我告诉你，你永远猜不到会被剪掉。哦，太棒了。今天的嘉宾是？这个人不会被放过，因为你会想看到这个人，而雇用这个人的人希望这个人在他们所做的每一件事的每一个画面中都出现。因为这是一个多年来出现在许多画面中的人。这是一个真正经历过各种风雨的人。
Started in New York, first professional job was an understudy. The queen. Yeah, and then moved into TV, did the whole thing, paid or dues in TV, guest stars on all the biggest shows and pilots and shows that lasted three episodes and six episodes. And then got a show that clicked
从纽约开始，第一份专业工作是候补演员。女王。是的，然后转战电视圈，经历了这一切，在电视圈里付出了努力，在所有最大的剧集、试播集以及只播了三集的剧和六集的剧里客串。然后接拍了一部一炮而红的剧——
in the biggest way. I got it. It's not friend-dressure. Clicked in the way that people just loved and couldn't get enough of. And guess what happens when you do that? People start saying we need to put you into our film and boy did she start doing films.
以最大程度地一炮而红。我懂了。不是《老友记》那样的。以人们深深喜爱并且百看不厌的方式一炮而红。你猜当你这么做的时候会发生什么？人们开始说我们需要把你放到我们的电影里，天哪，她真的开始拍电影了。
Big, huge commercial films. Big, huge, a war-d nominated in winning films. This person has done it all. You're not saying anything. All while being the mom to three kids and maintaining a consistency over time, which is really the mark of somebody who's incredible. Guys, I haven't given it away yet,
大型、巨大商业电影。大型、巨大、获得奖项提名和获奖的电影。这个人什么都做过了。你什么都没说。这一切的同时还要做三个孩子的妈妈，并随着时间的推移保持着一致性，这真的是一个非常了不起的人的标志。伙计们，我还没透露是谁，
but you know her from Alias, I hadn't given it away yet, but you know we're from Alias, you loved her in Daredevil, you knew her in Pearl Harbor. You like her in the estate? It's Jennifer Garner. See, Jen Garner? Oh, look at her.
但你从《双面女间谍》里认识她——我还没透露呢，但你知道我们从《双面女间谍》里认识她，你在《超胆侠》里很喜欢她，你在《珍珠港》里认识她。你在《地产姐妹》里喜欢她？是詹妮弗·加纳。看，詹妮弗·加纳？哦，看她。
Oh, that's it. She's back up. She's back up. Look at her. Hello. I usually have a baseball, okay, wait a minute. Jennifer Garner. Yeah, you always have a hat on. I usually have a baseball, okay, wait a minute. Jennifer, go ahead.
哦，就是这样。她上来了。她上来了。看她。你好。我通常戴着棒球帽——好吧，等等。詹妮弗·加纳。对，你总是戴着帽子。我通常戴着棒球帽——好吧，等等。詹妮弗，请继续。
Yeah, you always have a hat on. I always do. I always do. Yeah. You and Jason have the exact same glasses frames on right now. Listener, we've had a lot of nice people on this show. Sure. None is nice, is Jen.
对，你总是戴着帽子。我总是这样。我总是这样。对。你和杰森现在戴着一模一样的眼镜框。听众朋友们，我们在节目里接待过很多好人。当然。没有一个比詹妮弗更好。
Babe, man, I'm so happy to see you. Hi, guys, I got so nervous. Do people get nervous when you're about to introduce them? No, I have. I have a runny tummy right now. Always. Well, that's not, uh, people do, I think that, I don't know if people get nervous, but, but I think that nervous are always a good sign.
宝贝，天哪，见到你太高兴了。嗨，伙计们，我紧张得要命。大家在准备介绍他们时都会紧张吗？不，我有。我现在的胃在翻江倒海。总是这样。嗯，那不是，呃——人们确实，我想，我不知道人们是不是会紧张，但——但我认为紧张总是一个好兆头。
Okay, great. I mean, you're a real person. You're a great set. It means that you're in the moment. Uh, hi, Jennifer Garner. We've never met before. I know. That is so weird to me because I really remember you from the Venice moment. Hi, Jennifer Garner, we've never met before. I know, that is so weird to me,
太棒了。我的意思是，你是个真人。你是个好布景。这意味着你当下正专注其中。呃，嗨，詹妮弗·加纳。我们以前从未见过面。我知道。这对我来说太奇怪了，因为我真的记得你在威尼斯那几天的——嗨，詹妮弗·加纳，我们以前从未见过面。我知道，这对我来说太奇怪了，
because I really remember you from the Venice days and the whole, yeah, your whole compound. Yeah, the whole, I was in the compound with everybody who was in your show. What, you guys have never met? What compound? I know, it's not weird. When I was living out with Bradley,
因为我真的记得你在威尼斯那几天的情景，还有整个——对，你的整个大院。对，整个——我和你节目的每个人都在那个大院里。什么，你们从来没见过？什么大院？我知道，不是很奇怪吗。当我住在布拉德利那里时，
Bradley and I were in the back in Bon Rift and Iva. And Ron and Iva were in the front. Yeah. Where were you, John? How could you never meet if you guys were that close? when I went in the back in Ron and Iva. And Ron and Iva were in the front. Yeah. Where were you, Jen? How could you never meet if you guys were that close? I would kind of skulk around to try to avoid them. But you were living in the same building, Jen? No, no, I wasn't.
我和布拉德利在后面的邦里夫和伊娃那里。罗恩和伊娃在前门。对。你在哪儿，约翰？如果你们靠得那么近，怎么会从来没见过？——当我走到后面，罗恩和伊娃在那里。罗恩和伊娃在前门。对。你在哪儿，詹，如果你们靠得那么近，怎么会从来没见过？我会偷偷摸摸地试图避开他们。但你们住在同一栋楼里，詹？不，不，我没有。
It's just like Ron and Iva, Ron Riscan and his wife were in one part of this compound. And Ron was on Ilius. He played Sloan and Bradley Cooper was there. Right. And so, so when transpo was driving the van in the morning, picking up all the cast members, you're surprised. Oh, you might have seen this show. I don't know. It wasn't that kind of, this is sometimes
就像罗恩和伊娃——罗恩·里夫金和他的妻子在这个大院的一部分。罗恩在《双面女间谍》里，布拉德利·库珀也在那儿。对。所以，所以当交通车早上开着面包车来接所有演员时，你很惊讶。哦，你可能看过这个节目。我不知道。不是那种——有时
they saw Will taking out the garbage, but yeah, by the way, I didn't take out the garbage. That's why Ron got mad at me. Do you know that story? No, but I'm not surprised. I thought that's why you brought it up. I don't want Ron Riftkin running after Ron. I used to we were, I guess we're going to rest the development of the time. And I was never there for singing the morning on Monday, whatever it was or Thursday mornings. And at this point, Bradley moved out and Robbie Bates had moved into Bradley's place. Right, right, right.
他们看到威尔在倒垃圾，但是，顺便说一句，我没有倒垃圾。这就是罗恩生我气的原因。你知道那个故事吗？不，但我并不惊讶。我以为这就是你提起它的原因。我不想让罗恩·里夫金追着罗恩跑。我以前——当时我们正在拍《发展受阻》。而我星期一或周四早上的任何时候都不在那儿。此时布拉德利已经搬走了，罗比·贝茨已经搬进了布拉德利的地方。对，对，对。
Right. So Robbie was there and I go and all of a sudden like, Rob is kind of, I go, I think Ron's mad at me because I haven't taken the trash out because I don't get it. Why is it your job? It was anybody's job, whoever could do it. But Ron would do it right at 5 p.m. The moment you're allowed to put it out the night before you would put it out. And I'm like, I didn't get home till 7 a.m. at a clock from work.
对，所以罗比在那儿，然后我去，突然间——罗比有点——我说，我觉得罗恩生我的气了，因为我没有倒垃圾，我不明白。凭什么这是你的工作？这是任何人的工作，谁能干谁就干。但罗恩会在下午5点整去倒。就在你被允许在前一天晚上倒垃圾的那一刻，他就会把它倒出去。而我呢，我早上7点才从工作的地方回到家。
So I think he's mad at me and Robbie's like, oh, you're reading into it. You're being crazy. I'm like, okay. And like two months later, who was it who I saw? I saw somebody. And they said to me, oh, I ran, I ran into Ron Riftkin at a party and he says that you never take the trash out. I said, I knew it. And they said to me, oh, I ran into Ron Riftkin at a party and he says that you never take the trash out. I said, I knew it. And I said to Robbie, I'm like, who's crazy now? All right. If we don't cut me-
所以我认为他生我的气了，而罗比却说：“哦，你想太多了。你太疯狂了。”我说：“好吧。”大约两个月后，我看到了谁？我看到某个人了。他们对我说：“哦，我在一个派对上碰到了罗恩·里夫金，他说你从来不倒垃圾。”我说：“我就知道！”然后他们对我说：“哦，我在一个派对上碰到了罗恩·里夫金，他说你从来不倒垃圾。”我说：“我就知道！”我对罗比说：“到底谁才疯狂？”好吧。如果我们不把我——
You don't want that story? I'm checking out the NBC guard. You don't want the Ron Riftkin trash or your- People just run into it in double time. See, Jen, there's nothing to be nervous about. We don't let you get a word in edgewise. I know. It's like talking-
你不想听那个故事？我在查探NBC的警卫。你不想听罗恩·里夫金倒垃圾或者你的——人们只会加倍速度偶遇。看，詹，没什么好紧张的。我们根本不让你插话。我知道。就像说话——
It's Jennifer Garner, everybody. Yeah. so we don't let you get a word in as well. I know, just like talking. It's Jennifer Garner, everybody. Finally, you're the most delicious person. You're a so sweet and kind. What's with the 1950s microphone? I don't know, this just came. You're lovely guys, sonnet. We sent it over.
是詹妮弗·加纳，大家。对。所以我们不让你插话。我知道，就像说话一样。是詹妮弗·加纳，大家。终于，你是个最讨人喜欢的人。你太甜美善良了。这1950年代的麦克风是怎么回事？我不知道，这个刚送来。你们真可爱，小儿子。我们送过来的。
So Jennifer Garner, and I was, again, can I call you Jen? Yeah, unless you're gonna use the whole thing. I mean, does anybody call you Jenny? Not very few people. There's a first-day D that I love who calls me Jenny. Like people like that, just random people in my life, but I never mind, but.
所以，詹妮弗·加纳，我——再次，我可以叫你詹吗？可以，除非你想用全名。我的意思是，有人叫你珍妮吗？没有，极少数人。我有一个我很喜欢的副导演叫我珍妮。就像这样的人，我生活中的一些随机的人，但我从不介意，不过。
Well, you call Aniston Jenny sometimes. I always find it very cute. I think it's very affectionate. Yeah. I like Jenny as a nickname for Jen. Yes. In a weird way, but I didn't grow up as a Jenny. But I bet Jen Aniston would agree with me that we, you know, why weren't we named like
嗯，你有时也叫安妮斯顿“珍妮”。我总是觉得这很可爱。我觉得这非常亲切。对。我喜欢“珍妮”作为“詹”的昵称。是的。以一种奇怪的方式，但我成长过程中不叫珍妮。但我敢打赌詹·安妮斯顿会同意我的观点，我们——你知道，为什么我们不叫萨凡纳或爱尔兰之类名字呢？
Savannah or Ireland or something? Well, I also call Jason, I also call your wife Mandy. Nobody else calls her Mandy, but I like her. But, but so Jen, I want to go, I want to go way back because I love your, I love your trajectory. It's so great. And I mentioned it in the lead in when I was reading about you that all the frames. Yeah, well, I also, I felt very similar in that like I could,
嗯，我还叫杰森——我也叫你妻子曼迪。没有其他人叫她曼迪，但我喜欢她。但是——但是，詹，我想回到过去——我想回到很久以前，因为我喜欢你的——我喜欢你的发展轨迹。太棒了。我在引言中读到你时提到过，所有的画面。是的，嗯，我也有同感，觉得——当
when I looked at all the stuff that you did and the shows that got canceled in the three episodes and this stuff, that was my pain for so many years as well. You had all these near miss and you think like, oh, this is though, I'm so excited about this show. And then before you know it. Yeah, this is the one before you know, and JB, you know what it's like too. Oh my God.
我看着你做过的一切，那些只播了三集就被砍掉的节目，这很多年来也是我的痛楚。你有过所有这些擦肩而过的时刻，你会想，“哦，这个——天哪，我对这个节目太兴奋了。”然后不知不觉中——是的，这就是那个，不知不觉中，JB，你也知道那种感觉是什么样的。天哪。
All of a sudden it's gone. And you're like, what? I remember, I did a movie, my first like movie movie was Mr. McGoo with starring Leslie Nielsen as Mr. McGoo. Oh my God, remember that. Sure you do. I do. And when it was coming out, I knew so little
突然之间它就没了。你会想，什么？我记得，我拍过一部电影，我第一部真正的电影是《布谷鸟先生》，由莱斯利·尼尔森主演。哦，天哪，记得那个。你当然记得。我记得。当它上映时，我懂得太少
that I thought, well, I guess I get to go to the Oscars this year because I'm in a movie. I seriously was like, well, I guess. I get to dress. I better I guess. I better get ready. I better go shopping. Is it true that Leslie Nielsen, every day of his life, walked around with a little fart machine in his pocket?
以至于我想，“嗯，我想我今年可以去参加奥斯卡了，因为我演了一部电影。”我当时真的很认真地想，“嗯，我想我可以去盛装打扮了。我最好——我想我最好准备一下。我最好去购物。”莱斯利·尼尔森是不是真的生活中的每一天都在口袋里揣着一个小放屁机到处走？
He did. There was a fart machine. Yeah. I think that's so awesome. That'd be good. There's also this guy and I can't remember who it was. Or there wasn't a machine, but there was farting. Oh boy.
他真的带了。有一个放屁机。对。我觉得这太棒了。那挺好的。还有这个家伙，我不记得是谁了。或者没有机器，但确实有放屁。哦，天哪。
There was another. There was another. I was gonna say, Jay doesn't need a machine. There's a guy, I feel like it's not Jeffrey Tambor, but it's somebody like that equally hilarious that, oh, his bit, his whole life is to walk around with a little bit of loose change in his pocket and he just drops it as he walks by people. Right? What's his, what's his, what's his, because you can't help but go, oh, sir, you, you know, like, you just keep walking.
还有另一个。还有另一个。我刚要说，杰森不需要机器。有一个家伙——我觉得不是杰弗里·坦伯尔，但大概是那种同样搞笑的人——哦，他的绝招，他一生的乐趣就是口袋里揣着一点零钱到处走，当他从别人身边走过时就把它们扔在地上。对吧？他的绝招是什么，他的绝招是什么，因为你忍不住会说：“哦，先生，你——你知道的，就像，你只是继续走。”
You just drop and you change. It's a great tip. It's a great tip. So, first, so you're shopping for the Oscars after Mr. McGue, Happy Birthday to another great bit. Just say that, like, in an elevator. I don't know. Sorry, Willie.
你只是扔下零钱。这真是一个绝妙的招数。这是一个绝妙的招数。所以，首先——所以你在拍完《布谷鸟先生》后去为奥斯卡购物。那是什么？你在《布谷鸟先生》之前做过什么？你在那之前做过一堆节目吗？第一个是什么……而且，顺便问一句，你以前不也是个戏剧书呆子吗？对，我以前是个戏剧书呆子。好吧，那我们回去吧。好吧，我们回去……
So, you're ready to go to the Oscars after Mr. McGoo. What was the thing? What had you done before Mr. McGoo? You had done a bunch of shows before then? What was the first... And by the way, weren't you with theater nerd too? Yeah, I was a theater nerd. Well, let's go back then. Well, let's go back and...
我们回去。你最初是一个……你一开始不是戏剧专业，对吗？没错，我是化学专业。哇。哇。你现在还拥有那种热爱化学的大脑吗？不，不，不。我想我当时也没有。我只是觉得我爸爸是个化学——
Let's go back. You started as a... You weren't a theater major to begin with, is that true? Correct, I was a chemistry major. Wow. Wow. Do you have that kind of the brain that loves that still? No, no, no. I don't think I had it then. I just think my dad was a chemical...
他是个退休的化学工程师，我觉得我爸爸是个化学工程师。他是个退休的化学工程师，我来自一个化学小镇。就像那是联合碳化物公司、陶氏化学、杜邦公司。是的，大概还有五个人知道我真的有一种——饮用水一定很美味。它五颜六色的。彩虹播放器。当然。不过你有没有那种科幻大脑，就是你喜欢科幻，因为《双面女间谍》和那些东西，还是没有？没有。嗯——嗯。不，好吧，你不需要那样。
He's a retired chemical engineer, think my dad was a chemical engine. He's a retired chemical engineer and I come from a chemistry town. Like it was Union Car by Dow, DuPont. Yeah, there are like five people left knowing I really do have a like a drinking water must be delicious. It's all different colors. Rainbow players. Sure. Do you have a sci-fi brain though that you that you do like sci-fi, because of alias and all that, or no? No. Mm-mm. No, well, you don't have to be that.
不，我只是在想。你会觉得，但没有，我只是……你的女儿们还没开始学化学吧？弗兰尼在学化学吗？我不知道，她在学。哦，天哪，我女儿上高二。是的，那她就是在学。是的，她化学学完了。
No, I'm just thinking. Like, you would think that, but no, I just... Your girls aren't taking chemistry yet. Are they Franny's taking chemistry? I don't know, she's doing it. Oh my gosh, my daughter's a junior. Yes, so then she is. Yes, she's done with chemistry.
是的，你的多大了？弗兰尼16岁，梅普尔11岁。哦，哇。好吧，我有16岁、14岁和11岁的。你有帮她们辅导化学吗？不，不，不。不，你什么都没记住。我不记得了。
Yeah, how old are yours? For any 16 and Maple is 11. Oh, wow. Okay, I have 16, 14 and 11. Are you helping out with chemistry at all? No, no, no. No, you didn't retain any of it. I don't remember.
我的意思是，真的，我无法帮我高二的女儿做那种家庭作业。甚至连看都几乎看不懂。数学呢？数学呢？数学呢？她昨天刚考了AP，我的天，BC微积分，AP，随便什么考试。那就是——是的，绝对的。
I mean, truly, I can't help with that homework of my high school junior. Not even, I can hardly read it. What about math? What about math? What about math? She had her AP, my heart, BC, Calc, AP, whatever, her exam yesterday. That's just, yeah, definitely.
绝对的。求导数，就像我甚至——你上一次处理抛物线是什么时候？你知道我的意思吗？好吧，今天，我觉得我们真的不应该必须做那个。杰森，我好久没见你了。我知道。你知道吗？
Definitely. Derived it, like I don't even, when's the last time you dealt with a parabola? You know what I mean? Well, today, I feel like we really shouldn't have to do it. Jason, I haven't seen you in a long time. I know. You know?
还记得我们以前一起工作的时候吗，大概每八九个月一次？对，还记得我们以前总是在一起吗？你们拍过《朱诺》？我们拍了《朱诺》。还有什么？但在那之前，我们拍了《反恐王国》。哦，你拍了《反恐王国》，当然。
Remember when we used to work together, like once every eight or nine months? Yeah, remember when we were together all the time? You guys did Juno? We did Juno. What else? But before that, we did the Kingdom. Well, you did the Kingdom, of course.
《反恐王国》是在《朱诺》之前吗？《反恐王国》在《朱诺》之前。我们没一起拍过第三部吗？拍过，我总是忘，我其实查了一下，因为我们没有对手戏。这就是为什么。哦，那是里奇·热维斯的片子。那是《发明谎言》，对。
Was Kingdom before Juno? Kingdom was before Juno. Didn't we do a third thing together? We did, and I always forget, and I actually looked it up because we didn't have scenes together. That's why. Oh, it was a Ricky Jervais. It was invention of lying, yes.
对，对。哦，我喜欢那部电影。对。现在，插播一则赞助商广告。大家请和我一起向ZipRecruiter对他们的支持表示热烈感谢。如果没有ZipRecruiter，做这档节目会很难。不过，如果他们能帮我们请到——
Yes, yes. Oh, I love that movie. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. Everybody, please join me with a big thank you. Does it precrooter for their support? Without zipper cruder, it would be hard to do this. What would be really helpful, though, if they could get us,
如果他们能——如果他们在听的话，我想请霍华德·斯特恩上节目，如果他们能在那里帮我们一把，或者巴拉克·奥巴马。那就太棒了。拜托，ZipRecruiter，你们太棒了。你们在做你们该做的事。请为了我们做这件事吧。因为毕竟，拒绝一个人的私人邀请是很难的。
if they could, if they're listening, I'd like to get Howard Stern on the show, if they can help us out there, or about Barack Obama. That would be fantastic. Please, zipper cruder, you're fantastic. You're doing what you do. Do it for us, please. Because after all, it is hard to turn down
所以想象一下，如果你正在招聘，你可以向你心仪职位的顶尖候选人发送私人邀请。好吧，现在你可以了。通过ZipRecruiter的“邀请申请”功能。现在，你可以免费试用ZipRecruiter，网址是zipperkruder.com/smartless。
a personal invitation. So just imagine if you're hiring, and you could send a personal invitation to the top candidates for your job. Well, now you can. With Zippercruder's invite to apply feature. And right now, you can try Zippercrooder for free at zippercrooder.com slash smartless.
ZipRecruiter的“邀请申请”功能是如何工作的？首先，ZipRecruiter的技术会为你找到并发送最符合你职位要求的候选人。然后你可以查看这个精选列表，只需点击一下按钮，就能邀请你真正感兴趣的人来申请你的职位。当你向你最喜欢的候选人发送私人邀请时，这会让他们知道他们是你的首选之一，
How does Zippercrooders invite to apply feature work? Well, first, Zippercrooders technology finds and sends you the most qualified candidates for your job. Then you can review this curated list and invite the ones you're really interested in to apply to your job at the click of a button. And when you send out personal invites to your favorite candidates, it lets them know that they're one of your
并且他们更有可能申请。邀请ZipRecruiter成为你的招聘平台。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天就能找到优质候选人，大家。亲自去看看吧。访问这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter，zipperkruder.com-smartless。再次重申，那是zipperkruder.com-slash-smartless，本期节目由BetterHelp赞助。现在，我打高尔夫球，有时高尔夫对我来说非常具有镇静作用。
top choices and they'll be more likely to apply. Invite Zippercrooter to be your hiring platform. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercrooter get a quality candidate within the first day, everybody. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder 4 free, zippercruder.com-smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com-slash-smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, I play some golf, and sometimes golf is very calming for me.
某种程度上，它是我的心理良药，但有时它并不让人平静，有时它气死人了。我有时需要工具来平衡我的生活，而心理治疗，我想，可以给我这些工具来在我的生活中找到更多的平衡。也许这也能为你工作。这样你就可以在不抛弃自己的情况下继续支持其他人。这对我很管用。当我处于一个良好的状态时，我对别人也会很好。BetterHelp可以帮你成为最好的自己，这样你就可以，你知道的，把多余的关爱分享给其他人。所以如果你在
It's sort of, it is my help, but sometimes it's not calming, sometimes it's infuriating. I need tools to balance my life sometimes, And therapy, I guess, could give me those tools to find more balance in my life. And maybe that could work for you too. So you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. It's worked for me. When I'm in a good place, I can be good for other people. Better help can help you be the best you can be so you can, you know, share a little of that surplus with other folks. So if you're
考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行。它旨在提供便利、灵活性，并适合你的日程安排。你只需填写这份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。通过BetterHelp寻找更多平衡。今天就访问BetterHelp.com-smartless，首月可享10%的优惠。那是BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-smartless。本期节目由FX的《熊家餐馆》赞助支持。
thinking about starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient, flexible, and it's suited to your schedule. You just fill out this brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-smartless. This episode is supported by FX is the bear.
热播剧集携杰瑞米·艾伦·怀特回归，他凭借该剧荣获金球奖最佳男主角，饰演卡米。他和团队将把他们的家庭三明治店改造为一个顶级场所，同时他们被迫以新的方式团结在一起，面对他们的过去，并重新思考他们在未来想成为什么样的人。FX的《熊家餐馆》，所有剧集于6月22日独家登陆Hulu流媒体开播。现在回到节目中。所以你成了一个戏剧书呆子，你在丹尼斯转了专业，你不想成为一个格伦·乔尼尔，你成了——你在布景上工作，你做了所有这些事情，你知道的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后呢？你就像，好吧，我毕业了，我要离开这里，我要一直去工作。好吧，所以我毕业后的那个夏天，在佐治亚州亚特兰大的一家莎士比亚艺术节工作。当我们在那里时，有一部音乐剧，
The hit series returns with Jeremy Allen White in the Golden Globe winning role of Karmie. He and the team will transform their family sandwich shop into a next level spot all while being forced to come together in new ways as they confront their past and reckon with who they want to be in the future. FX is the bear, all episodes streaming streaming June 22nd only on Hulu. And now back to the show. So you become a theater nerd, you're at Dennis and you switch majors, you don't want to become
这部热门剧集携杰瑞米·艾伦·怀特回归，他凭借该角色荣获金球奖。他和团队将把家族三明治店改造为顶级餐厅，同时在面对过去和思考未来时，被迫以全新的方式凝聚在一起。FX出品的《熊家餐馆》，所有剧集将于6月22日独家登陆Hulu。现在回到节目。所以你成了戏剧迷，你在丹尼斯大学时换了专业，你不想成为
a glenjonier, you become, you're working on the sets, you're doing all this stuff, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then what? You're like, all right, I graduate, I'm out of here and I'm gonna go and work all the time. Okay, so then I worked at a Shakespeare Festival in Atlanta, Georgia, the summer after I graduated. And while we were there, there was a musical,
格伦乔尼尔，你开始参与布景工作，做各种事情，你知道，等等等等。然后呢？你就像是，好吧，我毕业了，我要离开这里，然后我要一直去工作。好的，所以我毕业后的那个夏天在佐治亚州亚特兰大的一家莎士比亚戏剧节工作。我们在那里的时候，有一部音乐剧，
because I really, I loved musicals. And there was a musical, a new version of what's it called? Taming of the Shrew. Okay. Okay it called, Taming of the Shrew. Okay. Okay. What is Taming of the Shrew is the name of the, which is Kiss Me Kate, there's Kiss Me Kate, but apparently there needed to be another one.
因为我真的很，我喜欢音乐剧。当时有一部音乐剧，是那个叫什么来着的新版本？《驯悍记》。好吧。好吧，它叫《驯悍记》。好吧。好吧。《驯悍记》是那个剧的名字，就是《吻我，凯特》，有《吻我，凯特》，但显然还需要另一个。
So it was called Dancing with the One I Love. And so that show was taken to a theater in a strip mall in Fort Lauderdale, called the Brian the Brian C Smith Off-Broadway Theater. Uh-huh. And I- Uh-huh. We're still with you. This is next to TurboTax.
所以它叫《与我爱的人共舞》。然后那个演出被带到了劳德代尔堡一个露天购物中心的剧院，叫做布莱恩·C·史密斯外百老汇剧院。嗯哼。然后我——嗯哼。我们还陪着你呢。这就在百思买（TurboTax）旁边。
Right. It literally was. It was shut down for tax evasion later. Oh, no, sure. But I went down with that show and performed there. And I was there as a non-equity performer because I had been hiding from my equity card because I could work more, you know?
没错。字面意思确实如此。它后来因为逃税被查封了。哦，不，当然。但我跟着那个演出去了那里并在那里表演。我在那里是一名非演员公会（non-equity）演员，因为我一直在躲着我的演员工会卡，这样我就能多接点活儿，你知道吧？
Yeah, right. So I was working as a non-equity performer. So I didn't have, they didn't have to put me up. So in exchange for being someone's roommate, I was in charge of the laundry for the entire cast and there were 35 men. We did eight shows a week. So I washed and ironed all there,
对，没错。所以我当时是一名非演员公会演员。因此我没有，他们不用给我提供住宿。所以作为和别人合租公寓的交换，我负责整个剧组的洗衣服工作，当时有35个男演员。我们一周演八场。所以我洗并烫了他们所有的衣服，
but I got really good at ironing. No way! Yeah, I did all of the washing drying, all of the dry cleaning. I can't touch anyone's dirty clothes. I love dirty clothes. It can't do it. I want to iron your little ponchos so bad.
但我熨衣服变得非常厉害。真的假的！对，我包办了所有的水洗、烘干、所有的干洗。我碰不了别人的脏衣服。我爱死脏衣服了。我可做不到。我太想熨你那些小斗篷了。
And your hand goes in the wrong spot. Oh gosh. I can't be. You're gonna look for the waistband, grab that. Oh my god. Do you love that? Of all household chores you love ironing? Like do you love that?
结果你的手放错了地方。哦天哪。我可不行。你会去摸腰带，然后抓住那个。哦天哪。你喜欢这个？在所有的家务里你最喜欢熨衣服？我是说你真的喜欢吗？
I have a friend that loves ironing. Yeah, I got that. I got really into it at the time. I was so, I just ironed all the time. So yeah. I used to be one of my chores on the weekends. I just learned a new hack is to, if you have rings on a wood table, something like that.
我有个朋友特别喜欢熨衣服。对，我当时迷上了。我当时太，我无时无刻不在熨衣服。所以，是的。这曾经是我周末的家务之一。我刚学了一个新诀窍，就是如果你木头桌子上有水杯印之类的东西。
And you put like a, just a damp towel on it and you iron it and it'll bring the ring mark off. Maybe you guys already got. Oh my god. I learned it on the TikTok. Hey, so listen. You tube shorts. Yeah, you tube shorts.
你放一块，只要放一块湿毛巾在上面然后用熨斗烫一下，就能把印子去掉。也许你们早就知道了。哦天哪。我是从TikTok上学的。嘿，听着。YouTube短视频。对，YouTube短视频。
They call cute lots. So, Jen, so you're in Florida, you're doing a ton of laundry and Hollywood calls. I was doing a ton of laundry. And after it was over, I was driving North to audition for... Back to Georgia. From, yeah, I was driving up North to audition for Utah Shakespeare for the next summer.
他们叫可爱乐。所以，珍，你在佛罗里达，你要洗大量的衣服，然后好莱坞在召唤。我当时在洗海量的衣服。等演出结束后，我正开车往北去试镜……回佐治亚州。从，对，我正开车往北去为犹他莎士比亚戏剧节接下来的夏天做试镜。
And when I was on my way there, I met a casting director in Philadelphia at a restaurant and he said, you should come and read for this little movie. Anyway, I ended up in New York for a couple of days. And while I was there, I went on an audition. And I, actually, I opened the backstage, I went on a bunch of auditions. And because I was so green and so fresh off the bus,
就在我去的路上，我在费城的一家餐馆遇到了一位选角导演，他说，你应该来为这部小电影试镜。总之，我在纽约待了几天。当我在那儿的时候，我去参加了一个试镜。而且我，实际上，我打开了后台，我去了好多试镜。因为我太稚嫩、刚进城，
like West Virginia girl, I just got everything that day that I went on. They were all these little non-equity jobs. It was just one of those days, you know? It's just like, it's my first day in New York, hi. I'd hire you right now based on this interview. It's unbelievable, right? So somebody said you should meet an agent.
就像个西弗吉尼亚女孩，我那天去的面试全都通过了。那全是一些小型非演员公会的工作。你知道，就是那种日子之一，懂吗？就像，这是我在纽约的第一天，嗨。根据这次采访我现在就雇用你。这太不可思议了，对吧？所以有人说你应该去见一个经纪人。
I met this agent. She said, I want to send you to the roundabout to see if you could get an understudy job. And so anyway, then I did. And then I started working at Isabella's. Do you remember Isabella's on the southeast corner of 77th Street and Columbus Avenue? Yes, that's a bar. Yes of 77th Street and Columbus Avenue? Yes.
我见了这个经纪人。她说，我想把你送到圆形剧场（Roundabout）去看看能不能拿到一个候补（understudy）的工作。总之，然后我去了。接着我开始在伊莎贝拉餐厅工作。你还记得77街和哥伦布大道东南角的伊莎贝拉餐厅吗？记得，那是个酒吧。对，在77街和哥伦布大道？对。
That's a bar. Yes, I do. Yeah, restaurant. Yeah, it was across from the Natural Museum of History. Yes, I know Isabella's. Yeah. Do you ever get loaded in there, Will? I sure did.
那是家酒吧。对，我记得。对，是个餐厅。对，它在自然历史博物馆对面。对，我知道伊莎贝拉餐厅。对。威尔，你有没有在那里喝醉过？我当然有。
But that was a different life time. So how quickly after that were you back on the bus out to Hollywood? A few years. Because I only wanted to do theater. Right. And you have this amazing singing voice that not a lot of people know that you have, but you do. No.
但那是另一辈子了。所以在那之后多久你又坐上巴士去了好莱坞？几年后。因为我只想演戏剧。没错。而且你有着一副很棒的歌喉，虽然没多少人知道你有，但你确实有。没有。
But so that was the dream to do musicals on Broadway. Never to go out to Hollywood. I mean, it was just to be in theater. I didn't really, I mean, I love dancing. I don't really have a voice that could be a professional singing voice unless it's like the range from, you know, here to here. But Broadway quality.
不过这就是梦想，在百老汇演音乐剧。从来没想过去好莱坞。我的意思是，只是为了演戏剧。我真的不，我是说，我喜欢跳舞。我其实没有那种能成为专业歌手的嗓音，除非音域是，你知道的，从这到这。但要有百老汇的水平。
Yeah, I don't have like a Broadway voice, but I have a karaoke voice. We've done karaoke sort of, Fancy karaoke. But anyway, yeah, then I was super broke and I had just finally auditioned for a TV thing. This agent sent me on and she said, well, they want to test you for this. And I said, I'm understudying right now. And she said, they'll give you $150 a day cash per deum.
对，我没有百老汇那样的嗓音，但我有卡拉OK嗓。我们唱过卡拉OK之类的，高级卡拉OK。总之，是的，当时我穷得叮当响，我刚刚终于去为一个电视剧试镜了。一个经纪人把我派过去的，她说，他们想让你为这个试镜。我说，我正担任候补呢。她说，他们一天会给你150美元的现金补贴。
And I so badly needed that cash. I was so broke that I came to LA to test for something and I got that job and it was to play Melissa Gilbert's daughter in a Daniel Steel mini series. So then I did that. Oh my god. Yeah. I was up for the same part. Wow.
我太需要那些现金了。我穷得叮当响，以至于我来到洛杉矶为某个角色试镜，而且我拿到了那份工作，是在丹妮尔·斯蒂尔（Daniel Steel）的迷你剧中饰演梅丽莎·吉尔伯特（Melissa Gilbert）的女儿。于是我就演了。哦天哪。对。我也竞争过同一个角色。哇。
Wow. Melissa Gilbert was one of my first crushes. Yeah, you guys are so tied to each other because I was just thinking, Jay, you worked with Melissa Gilbert on Little House. Yes, sir. Yeah. That's right.
哇。梅丽莎·吉尔伯特是我年轻时的偶像之一。对，你们俩联系太紧密了，因为我刚才在想，杰伊，你曾在《草原小屋》里和梅丽莎·吉尔伯特合作过。是的，长官。对。没错。
Things all started to happen for me. Testosterone and my career. I kept calling her Laura. I remember in here in makeup, I kept calling her Laura. Did you really? Yeah. Yeah.
一切对我来说都开始发生了。睾酮和我的职业生涯。我一直叫她劳拉。我记得在这里化妆的时候，我一直叫她劳拉。真的吗？对。对。
She taught me everything I'd never been in front of, I'd never been in front of a camera. I'd never paid attention to any of it. She taught me what a call she was, who to talk to for things. She taught me about the camera turning around. I had no, I was totally clueless. Oh my God, that's so sweet.
她教会了我一切，我以前从没在镜头前出现过，我以前从来没在镜头前呆过。我从来没注意过这些。她教会了我什么是通告，遇到事情该跟谁说话。她教会了我镜头是怎么转的。我完全一无所知，彻底懵懂。哦天哪，太贴心了。
That's so nice. Did you guys, did you stay connected with her at all after? Yeah, I have. You know, she's in government and politics. Yeah, I had a fundraiser for it. Yep. Married to Timothy Bussfield. Yeah, very happily.
太好了。你们俩，后来跟她还有联系吗？对，我有。你知道的，她现在搞政府政治。对，我还为她办过募捐活动。是的。嫁给了蒂莫西·巴斯菲尔德（Timothy Bussfield）。对，非常幸福。
The great Timothy Bussfield, yeah. Couple of genders. Yeah, yeah. Found each other. Well, my son's a genders, so I always have a soft spot. One of my sweet, sweet ginger. Sweetable. So you do the movie with now you've,
伟大的蒂莫西·巴斯菲尔德，是的。一对红发人。对，对。找到了彼此。嗯，我儿子是红发，所以我对红发总是情有独钟。我一个甜美可人的红发宝宝。讨人喜欢。所以你拍了那部电影，现在你有了，
and then she's taught you everything you need to know about showbiz in half hour. So then I'm in. So now you're in. Then I went back to New York and I would, every time I would get some kind of play, I would be so broke. I would get an episode of Lawn Order or some dumb thing and I would take that job because I needed that top show. Well, you did Lawn order, right? I did. Scale plus 10. Scale plus 10. You're just so stupid.
然后她用半小时教会了你娱乐圈的一切。然后我进圈了。所以现在你进圈了。接着我回到了纽约，每当我接到某种戏剧演出时，我都穷得要命。我会接一集《法律与秩序》或者什么傻里傻气的东西，我会接那份工作因为我需要那笔通告费。嗯，你演过《法律与秩序》，对吧？我演过。演员公会最低片酬加10%。最低片酬加10%。你太蠢了。
But also you're working in the city. And as you, like you, like you're working in the city, you're so excited that you get to shoot in the city. And you end up like shooting on, so you're like, I was just here yesterday. Byin, milk, and now I'm here shooting at, you know what I mean? You're so crazy. Isn't it when you're're when you first or drive or
但同时你又在城里工作。而且当你在，就像你，就像你在城里工作时，你兴奋极了，因为你能在城里拍戏。结果你最后在，比如你会想：我昨天才刚来过这儿买牛奶，现在我居然在这儿拍戏，你懂我的意思吗？你太疯狂了。当你第一次开车或者
Going up somewhere and you see like you know big caravans and whole set in a base camp and you're like wow There's a movie shooting there and you're like wait a minute. That's me. Yeah, do you remember that? Yeah, I still feel that way I still get that way up don't drive in up to location and just seeing all the trucks Yeah, yeah Because I remember like moving to Los Angeles for the trucks. It's like, yeah. Yeah, because I remember like moving to Los Angeles for the first time seeing that and like just waiting tables and you're like, that'd be so cool. What are they filming over there?
去某个地方，看到那些大篷车和整个剧组的根据地时，你会想：哇，那边在拍电影，然后你一想：等等，那是我。对，你还记得吗？对，我至今还是这种感觉。我开车开到外景地看到那些大卡车时还是会有这种感觉。因为我记得当年为了这些卡车搬到洛杉矶。就像是，对。对，因为我记得第一次搬到洛杉矶看到这些，然后在餐厅当服务员，你会想：那边在拍什么，看起来真酷。我也好想参与进去。
I'd love to be a part of it. Yeah. How did, so, so right off the bus from West Virginia, you're in New York, you're very green. How did that, how, how did you find the city? Was it, was it scary or did you adapt immediately? I was pretty happy. I mean, I just, I really went right into it. I just would pay my $20 to stand at the back of the Broadway
话说，从西弗吉尼亚刚下巴士，你就到了纽约，非常青涩。你当时觉得这座城市怎么样？是觉得可怕还是立刻就适应了？我挺高兴的。我是说，我真的直接就融入了。我只会花20美元站在百老汇剧场的最后面，独自一人看我能看的所有演出，就像这样。我还会去博物馆。我是说，我当时就是个狂热的书呆子。
house to watch every show that I could by myself like this. And I would go to museums. And I mean, I just was nerding out. So you weren't going to the discos in the bars in the... No, it wasn't doing any of that. But my mom always told me that the more people you make eye contact with and smile at during this day on the street, like strangers,
所以你没有去迪斯科舞厅和酒吧……没有，我根本没去过那些地方。但我妈妈总是告诉我，白天在街上走的时候，你跟越多的人有眼神接触并向他们微笑，比如陌生人，
the happier you are as a person. So, oh, the cuckoo clocks, right? But so as I was walking down... Does that go off every time you caught having cuckoo your mom said? Yes, it would be very busy. Wait, why it? Wait, by the way, by the way,
作为一个人的你就会越快乐。所以，哦，布谷鸟钟，对吧？但是当我走在路上……每次你一说到你妈的话题它就会响吗？对，它会非常忙。等等，为什么是它？等等，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，
there's a, that was Kuku. There's a lot of wisdom in that, because I like that your mom said that, and I was just listening to a thing today, because it is, it lends itself to the Kuku Plexi Maltes. We get locations on the Kuku Plexi. Yeah, I wish Melissa Gilbert had told you about the sound of the roller.
有个，那是布谷鸟。这里面有很多智慧，因为我喜欢你妈妈说的那句话，我今天刚好听到一个说法，因为它确实，这很符合布谷鸟钟的特质。我们在布谷鸟钟的所在地拍摄。对，我真希望当年梅丽莎·吉尔伯特能跟你讲讲滚轮的声音。
I got to deal with that. Kuku. So there's a lot of wisdom in that. I like this idea that it's kind of, you know, you get what you put out there. And so, and I think that that's true. If you go out and you make eye contact and you smile at people and you kind of, you project joy, you're going to get joy coming back anyway. Yeah, right.
我得对付这个。布谷鸟。所以这里面有很多智慧。我喜欢这种想法，就是种瓜得瓜，种豆得豆。而且我认为这是真的。如果你走出去，跟别人有眼神接触，对别人微笑，散发快乐，无论如何你也会收获快乐。对，没错。
Okay, but when you first moved to New York, Well, that's crazy. Yeah, that is very hard on the population of New York. I was very tiring. I was like, hi, hi, how you doing? Nice day. I like your shoes. I mean, it was a lot.
好吧，但当你刚搬到纽约时，好吧，这太疯狂了。对，这对纽约的人口来说太难了。我当时累坏了。我总是：嗨，嗨，你好吗？天气真好。我喜欢你的鞋子。我是说，这太夸张了。
I was, I was a lot. Well, you can't compliment people's shoes in New York. But, but when you're, where was your first apartment? Do you remember what part of the city? Yeah. I lived on a woman's kitchen floor on 85th and Broadway. Wow. She had a studio, but the kitchen was kind of its own alcove
我当时，我当时太热情了。好吧，在纽约你可不能随便夸别人的鞋子。不过，但是，你的第一个公寓在哪里？你还记得在城市的哪个区吗？对。我借住在85街和百老汇大街交界处一个女人的厨房地板上。哇。她有个单间公寓，但厨房有点像个独立的凹室，
and I had a little futon and my suitcase for nine months. Wow, like a puppy. What year was that? Yeah, a puppy. A puppy. 94. OK. Why were you on 85th and? No, I lived on, I lived on 87th and West What you was actually thinking. What you were, 94. Okay. Why were you on 85th and?
我在那里放了一张小折叠沙发和我的手提箱，住了九个月。哇，就像只小狗。那是哪一年？对，小狗。小狗。94年。好的。你为什么在85街？不，我住在，我住在87街和西区大街，
No, I lived at 87th in West End with five other people. That was like 90, 91. And then by 92, I was living on the upper east side in a railroad apartment with two other two. I'm on, Jen, I'm on 81st and Broadway right now. Oh, no way. No, I don't care. Wait, so.
那是90年、91年左右。然后到92年，我和另外两个人一起住在上东区的一套铁路式公寓（railroad apartment）里。珍，我现在就在81街和百老汇大街。哦，不会吧。不，我不在乎。等等，所以。
So, that's a nice apartment. Is that your apartment? Yes, brand new. And only does is watch TV in there. Yeah. So, so you do this. Now you're living there, you're living in New York and you're doing some, you're doing law and order,
所以，那是个好公寓。那是你的公寓吗？是的，全新的。而且里面唯一的活动就是看电视。对。所以，你做到了。现在你住在那儿，你住在纽约，你在演一些，你在演《法律与秩序》，
you're doing Spin City, kind of go back and watch your Spin City episode. Yeah, you do. I'm shocked that you haven't. I know, I know. And then, where does Aliess fall into all of this? Like, I'm well sorry, you meet JJ Abrams because you do Felicity.
你在演《城市大赢家》（Spin City），回去看看你的《城市大赢家》那一集吧。对，会的。我很震惊你竟然没看过。我知道，我知道。然后，Alias（双面女间谍）是在什么时候出现的？抱歉，我是说，你因为演了《大学生费莉希蒂》（Felicity）而认识了J·J·艾布拉姆斯（JJ Abrams）。
Yes, so a few years go by, and I had been working probably seven years by the time I met JJ and did Felicity and Alias. And how'd you meet JJ? I just auditioned for Felicity for a guest spot. Oh, gotcha. Wow. And then it was like you remember, do you?
是的，所以几年过去了，到我认识J·J并出演《费莉希蒂》和《双面女间谍》时，我大概已经工作七年了。你怎么认识J·J的？我只是去为《费莉希蒂》的一个客串角色试镜。哦，原来如此。哇。然后就像你记得的一样，你记得吗？
But I had heard and JJ is a friend of the show. So he's listening. I had heard that you, that he wrote Alias with you in mind. He did. I know, it's not cool. He gave it to me and I stood in one spot in my kitchen and read the pilot. I didn't even move. I was so, it was still, I think it's the best pilot.
但我听说，而且J·J是本节目的朋友。所以他在听。我听说你，他写《双面女间谍》时心里想的就是你。他确实是。我知道，这不是很酷吗。他把剧本交给我，我站在厨房的同一个地方读完了试播集。我连动都没动。我太，我觉得这是最棒的试播集。
I think. That's awesome. He's such an incredible director too. Yeah, it turned out. Yeah, it's such a great, it is a great pilot. And it was, and it was a, it was a great show and you're great on it and. I think it's his general energy. I mean, it is a great pilot. And it was, and it was a, it was a great show and you're great on it. And, um,
我认为是。太棒了。他也是个非常了不起的导演。对，事实证明确实如此。对，这是一部非常棒的剧，是一部伟大的试播集，你在这部剧里表现也棒极了。我认为这跟他整体的能量有关。我是说，这确实是个伟大的试播集。而且它是一部，这是一部很棒的剧，你在里面表现得很棒，而且，
I think it's his general energy. I mean, it's pretty infectious. It's so positive. Yeah. He gives you his full attention. Is super sincere? I just, but there's not a lot like that. And is that where you met our lovely Victor Garber
我觉得这源于他整体的活力。我是说，这种感染力极强。太积极了。对。他会给你百分之百的关注。超级真诚？我只是，但没有多少人像他这样。这就是你遇到我们可爱的维克托·加伯（Victor Garber）的地方吗？
that we have in common? Yes. That is where I met our lovely Victor Garber. Although I'd been a big fan of his, I'd seen him in art, I'd seen him in the one with Billy Cruda, that started with an A at Lincoln Center. I'd, you know, the one I'm talking about.
我们共同的朋友。是的。那就是我遇到我们可爱的维克托·加伯的地方。虽然我早就成了他的超级粉丝，我看过他演的《艺术》（Art），看过他演的由比利·克鲁德普（Billy Crudup）主演的、在林肯中心上演的以字母A开头的那个剧。我，你知道我在说哪个。
Yeah, Arcadia. Arcadia, thank you. Yeah, whenever we have dinner, whenever Victor and I got to dinner, he's a very close friend of both yours and mine. Mm-hmm. And all of a... He was at a premier party.
对，《阿卡迪亚》（Arcadia）。《阿卡迪亚》，谢谢。对，每当我们共进晚餐时，每当我和维克托去吃晚饭，他是你和我两人的至交好友。嗯。而且每当……他当时在一个首映派对上。
Or you're opening your... Yes, he was at the premier. Opening party or you're opening. Yes, or is that the opening night and Any time we go out to dinner, I'll always say super super loud. Oh my god. Were you in Titanic? And everybody looks and he's Is everyone's looking for Leonardo DiCaprio. Did you guys see him in God's Bell? Yes, Martin Short and and every other Canadian actor That's all. Is everyone's looking for Leonardo DiCaprio? Did you guys see him in God's Bell? Yes. With Martin Short and every other Canadian actor
或者你在开幕……是的，他在首映式上。开幕派对或者你在开幕。是的，或者那是首映之夜，无论什么时候我们出去吃晚饭，我总是会超大声地喊：哦天哪！你演过《泰坦尼克号》吗？然后每个人都看过来，而他却在……每个人都在寻找莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。你们看过他在《Godspell》里的演出吗？是的，和马丁·肖特以及其他所有加拿大演员。
that we've had on the show. Every Canadian actor. And they're all still super close, that entire cast. I know it. Really, it's like 40 years later. I love that. Wait, am I showing my dumbness by wondering why would they all be Canadians?
所有加拿大演员。而且整个剧组直到现在关系都超级好。我知道。真的，就像是40年之后。我真喜欢这样。等等，我是不是表现得很蠢，居然在想他们为什么全都是加拿大人？
It all really started. There was, like, so God Spell was this thing on Broadway. It was a huge sensation. Wait, wait, Jen, Jen, before I hate to interrupt you, but I have to, Jason, we've had at least five members of that production on the podcast who have talked about the fact that they were all in that production.
这一切其实都是从那开始的。当时，《Godspell》是百老汇的一部大戏。那真是一个巨大的轰动。等等，等等，珍，珍，虽然我不想打断你，但我必须得说，杰伊，我们已经在播客里请过至少五位那部剧的演员了，他们都聊过他们曾一起演过那部剧。
No recollection at all. I just thought maybe God Spell was written by a Canadian. It's a Canadian story and no. Yeah, Jesus, Jesus turns out was a Canadian. Everyone knew it. So, do you see this as in Godspell? Oh my God. Oh my God.
完全没有任何记忆。我只是以为《Godspell》是加拿大人写的。这是一个加拿大的故事，根本不是。对，结果耶稣是个加拿大人。人尽皆知。所以，你见过这个人在《Godspell》里的表演吗？哦天哪。哦天哪。
Godspell's not one word. There's two words. How do you spell? How do you spell God? So, so, G-A-W-D. Oh my God. Vector, and you know, I used to see Victor too
Godspell不是一个词。是两个词。怎么拼？God怎么拼？所以，G-A-W-D。哦天哪。维克托，你知道的，我以前也经常见到维克托，
back in the alias days. Through Bradley. Yeah. By the time, yeah. Yeah, and we would have dinner out on the west side with that little me and the rest of the cast of alias all the time,
在《双面女间谍》的时期。通过布莱德利（Bradley）。对。到那个时候，对。对，我们经常和那个小圈子——我还有《双面女间谍》的其他演员——一起在西区吃晚饭，
because Bradley was on alias. Mm-hmm. I felt like a sort of an eighth member of the cast, if you will. No, you won't. You won't. No, you won't. So, so, Ali's comes about, and then I remembered the time when Ali's came out, and it was so good,
因为布莱德利也演了《双面女间谍》。嗯哼。我感觉自己就像是剧组的第八位成员，如果你这么说的话。不，你才不是。才不是呢。不，你不是。所以，《双面女间谍》诞生了，然后我记得《双面女间谍》刚出的时候，它太棒了，
and it was so kickass, and there was so much written about. First of all, you were the lead of this show, and you were kickass lead, too. Yeah. Like, you just kind of, it's like you were shot out of a cannon and you were beaten fools up and knocking people out and crotch-hopping heads and doing shit and like all this spy stuff. And I remember the stories about you, your training regiment and how insane it was at the time. I still think about it to this day sometimes.
而且酷毙了，有那么多关于它的报道。首先，你是这部剧的主演，而且是一个超酷的女主角。对。就像你是被大炮轰出来的一样，你把坏蛋打得落花流水，把人打晕，飞踢别人的脑袋，做各种动作，还有所有这些间谍戏份。我还记得关于你的那些故事，你的训练日常在当时是多么疯狂。我至今有时还会想起它。
I'm going to admit to you something. I think about it sometimes when I think about getting up and working out before work and I'll think about you, the stories of you are embedded in my mind and I don't know you working out before doing alias. I swear to God. That is really. Wait, you would work out before shooting 12 hours a day? Yeah, I would because, Wait, you would work out before shooting 12 hours a day? Yeah, I would, because Carl Lumley, who was on the show, I started saying like, it's so hard for me to keep a workout. Our hours were so insane and I said,
我要向你坦白一件事。有时当我想起要在上班前起床锻炼时，我就会想起你，关于你的那些故事深深地印在我的脑海里，我不认识你在拍《双面女间谍》前是怎么锻炼的。我发誓。太……等等，你拍一天12小时的戏之前还要去锻炼？对，我会的，因为卡尔·伦利（Carl Lumbly），就是剧里的那位，我开始抱怨说：我太难坚持锻炼了。我们的工作时间太疯狂了，我说，
and I need to be warmed up and I just can't seem to get it all done. And he is such a state league, gorgeous man. And a theater actor and somebody I just respect so much. And at the time, like I had all these, I'd run, I had Victor, and I'd Carl all on the show. So I was looking up to them so much for anything. And Carl said, you can always do half an hour. You just set your clock, just get up and do it.
而且我需要先热身，但我好像怎么都抽不出时间搞定它。而他是一个那么有风度、那么帅气的男人。又是一个戏剧演员，是我极其尊重的人。当时，我的剧组里有这些大咖：我有维克托，还有卡尔。所以我对他们充满了仰慕，事事向他们看齐。卡尔说：你总是可以抽出半小时。你只要定好闹钟，起床去练就行了。
You can always do it. And so from that day, I was just like, oh, okay, then I will. And so just no matter what, I would crank my clock earlier to REE 45. You know, I would do anything to show up to work warmed up because there was so much action and I never, I didn't know when things were gonna happen
你总是能做到的。所以从那天起，我就想：哦，好吧，那我就练。于是无论如何，我都会把闹钟调早到4点45分。你知道的，为了以热身的状态出现在片场，我什么都愿意做，因为动作戏太多了，我从来不知道什么时候会发生什么，
and I just, I wanted to be ready for whatever. Now I don't do that. And now, like a six and an occasional five, but I don't, you know, not really. But isn't it depressing how much harder it is to stay in shape as we get older? I mean, it's almost like it doubles the amount of time you have to spend at it almost every year. I remember you solidly running six or seven miles every day. Never it never helped.
我只想为随时可能发生的一切做好准备。现在我可不那样了。现在大概是6点，偶尔5点，但真的不会了。不过，随着年龄增长，保持身材变得越来越难，这不是很让人沮丧吗？我是说，感觉几乎是每年你都得付出双倍的时间。我记得你以前雷打不动地每天跑步六到七英里。从来没用。
Never helped. It's still a running like I'm being chased. I also remember you spinning upside down in a car and just. And then you I remember you who were you pregnant with when you threw up? Was it violent? No, you already had violence. I was I was nursing. That was the issue.
从来没用过。依然跑得像后面有狗追一样。我还记得你在一辆翻倒的汽车里上下颠倒……然后我还记得你，你怀着谁的时候吐了？吐得那么厉害？不，你那时候已经没有了。我在哺乳期。问题出在这儿。
It was so hot where we were shooting the kingdom. Like we were in Arizona and it was August and September and 120 on asphalt. And we were wearing big boots and hats and bulletproof vests. And we, I went, that's the only time knock on wood. I've ever had to go to the hospital during shooting. I would get so dizzy, I couldn't see. I was nursing, I should have, you know. No way.
我们在拍《反恐王国》（The Kingdom）的时候片场太热了。我们在亚利桑那州，那是八月和九月，柏油路面上的温度高达120华氏度（约49摄氏度）。我们还穿着厚靴子、戴着帽子和防弹背心。然后我去了，谢天谢地，这是我拍戏期间唯一一次不得不去医院。我当时头晕得都看不清东西了。我在哺乳期，我本应该，你知道的。不会吧。
But I see, but on your Instagram, I see like you working out all the time. It's so inspiring. Like first of all, what, your mom, you work constantly, you work out, you're doing all these things. I see you do so many things. Like, is there, I asked this question a lot
但我看，但在你的Instagram上，我看到你一直在锻炼。太鼓舞人心了。首先，什么，你当妈妈，你一直在工作，你在锻炼，你在做所有这些事情。我看到你做了那么多事情。就像，有没有，我经常问这个问题，
because I find it fascinating. Is there a thing or a person that inspired you to be ambitious and to have this drive? Like where does that come from? To just do all of these things. I don't know, but don't you feel like you get older and you look around and there are people you admire and just like that moment with Carl?
因为我觉得这太迷人了。有没有一件事或一个人，激励你变得雄心勃勃、拥有这种拼劲？这动力是从哪里来的？去做好所有这些事情。我不知道，但难道你不觉得当你年纪渐长，环顾四周，看到那些你钦佩的人，就像卡尔当时的那个时刻吗？
Like something just like makes you realize, oh, I can do that. I can reach for that. I can go harder. I can reach for, I can go harder. I can reach for that. I can be more. Yeah, why not you? Jen, you're my curl.
就像某种东西让你意识到：哦，我能做到。我可以去争取那个。我可以更努力。我可以去争取，我可以更努力。我可以去争取那个。我可以变得更优秀。对，为什么不是你？珍，你就是我的卡尔。
That's what I'm trying to tell you. Oh, good. I'm so glad. I'll see you at, let's set the alarm. Let's face time. You could join me. But when you were younger, was there like a family member or a person where you just like something clicked in your head and you're like, wait a minute,
这就是我想对你说的。太好了。我太高兴了。回头见，我们定个闹钟。我们FaceTime联系。你可以加入我。但当你年轻的时候，有没有哪个家庭成员或某个人，让你脑子里“叮”地闪过一个念头，然后你想：等等，
I like how they live their life. I like how they kind of make the decisions they've made. I mean, I don't know, I have pretty great parents. Like they just, yeah. I'm pretty great, yeah. Do you find that your children are as motivated as you were at that age? They are, each of them in their own ways.
我喜欢他们生活的方式。我喜欢他们做出那些决定的方式。我是说，我不知道，我的父母相当棒。他们只是，对。我爸妈挺棒的，对。你发现你的孩子们像你当年一样有动力吗？他们都有，每个人都有他们自己的方式。
The hard thing is that you think it's gonna be your ways. And their ways are things I could never do and are they're amazing, but they are not, they keep forgetting to be me. Yeah. Yeah. Well, they, because it is fun. Do you find, well, Sean, do you find your dad? Oh, period. Sorry, sorry, that was just it. Just that one question. Sorry, sorry. Nobody is funny watching our kids, and this kind of goes out to everybody.
最难的是，你以为他们会走你的路。但他们的方式是我永远无法做到的，他们太棒了，但他们不是，他们总是忘了成为我。对。对。好吧，他们，因为这很有趣。肖恩，你觉得你爸爸——哦，句号。抱歉，抱歉，刚才只是顺口一问。就那一个问题。抱歉，抱歉。看着我们的孩子以跟我们不同的方式去闯荡，这感觉谁都会觉得挺逗的，这大概适用于所有人。
Like watching our kids have go about it in a different way than we went about it. Yeah. And I constantly find myself wanting to say like, hey, man, maybe if you, and then I'm just going, no, no, no, no, it's okay. He's going to do it his own way. I can, I'm just here to kind of act as bumpers on either side to keep them within a certain range.
就像看着我们的孩子以不同于我们的方式去面对生活。对。然后我经常发现自己想说：嘿，老兄，也许如果你……然后我马上转念一想：不，不，不，不，没关系。他会用他自己的方式去解决的。我能，我只是在这里充当两边的缓冲垫，把他们保持在某个合理的范围内。
Well, that's interesting though, because my, because of the way I was, we were raised in my dad and left early that old story, because of that, my two brothers who have kids are phenomenal dads. Wow. They're amazing. Yeah. I mean, it doesn't always go that way though. That's right, but I mean, that was the inspiration to be a great dad.
不过这很有意思，因为我的，因为我的成长方式——我们是在我爸爸很早就离家出走的家庭里长大的，就是那种老套的故事——正因如此，我的两个有孩子的兄弟都是了不起的爸爸。哇。他们太棒了。我是说，事情并不总是这样发展的。没错，但我的意思是，那成了做一个好爸爸的灵感来源。
Can I tell you something that happened the other night that I found really nice. I was with Jason and Amanda and Maple, who's 11 now, Maple, right? Yeah. And we were just talking about something and Maple was so honest and comfortable in this way and whatever. We all spend a lot of time. So when she told you to shut your mouth, when she said shut your your your stupid mouth, your stupid Canadian mouth. Yeah, you were saying something dumb. And I've been trying to keep from her that I'm Canadian for a long time. No, but she said, we started talking about something
我能跟你们分享一件前几天发生的事吗？我觉得特别温馨。我和杰伊、阿曼达还有梅普尔在一起，梅普尔现在11岁了，对吧梅普尔？对。我们当时在聊些什么，梅普尔表现得非常坦诚、自在，总之就是那样。我们大家花了很多时间在一起。所以当她叫你闭上你的臭嘴时，当她说“闭上你的臭嘴，你这张愚蠢的加拿大臭嘴”——对，你当时在说一些蠢话。而且我一直试图向她隐瞒我是加拿大人这件事，隐瞒了很久。不，但她说，我们开始谈论某事，
and she was really candid with you guys and with us in this way that felt that I really, I kind of loved, it was such a reflection of you and Amanda and I love seeing that in kids when they feel this level of comfort to share and be able to speak openly. I think that's so important. That's really rare. And it was, and it was, it was really heartwarming. Yeah. Well, that's nice.
她对你们和我们都非常坦诚，那种感觉让我，我挺喜欢的，那简直就是你和阿曼达的写照，我真的很喜欢在孩子们身上看到这种特质，当他们感到足够舒适去分享并能够坦率开口时。我觉得这太重要了。这真的很难得。而且，这真的很暖心。对，太好了。
Yeah. Thank you for saying that. I'm always surprised how little children really take from the parents. This whole question of nature versus nurture. And I think I've hammered this one before. But, you know, for whenever somebody says something nice about my kids, I just might instinctively deflect anyway. But I do think it is them, it is nature, it's not nurture. I think you can affect your kid probably 5% left or right,
谢谢你这么说。我总是很惊讶，孩子们其实从父母身上学到的东西是多么少。这就是先天与后天（nature versus nurture）的老问题了。我想我以前也强调过这个。但是，你知道，每当有人夸奖我的孩子时，我本能地还是会选择谦虚一下。但我确实认为这是天性（nature），而不是后天培养（nurture）。我认为你对孩子的影响大概只有正负5%左右，
you know, but for the most part, you get what you get. Cause like, you know, Jen, I'm sure you've got, you've got three to compare against. I've only got two where they're same parents, same, same roof, same upbringing, and they're wildly different. So there it is. You know, it's, it's, so it's not an answer. And from the minute they were born too, like their personalities were already intact. That's why I don't have kids. I don't want to wake up in the middle of the night and have them killing me. Right.
你知道的，但大部分情况下，基因决定一切。因为就像，你知道的，珍，我确信你有三个孩子可以作对比。我只有两个，同样的父母，同样的屋檐，同样的抚养方式，但他们截然不同。事实就是这样。所以，这不是靠培养出来的。而且从他们出生那一刻起，他们的性格就已经注定了。这就是为什么我不要孩子。我可不想半夜醒来发现他们把我给杀了。对。
Yeah, exactly. You could have an axe murder and you'd have nothing to do with it. You know what I'm saying? You should have recognized that if he had other that they would want to kill him. And I think that is a great room. But, Jen, what do you find now that we're on this?
对，没错。你可能会养出一个连环杀手，而这跟你一点关系都没有。你知道我在说什么吗？你应该意识到，如果他有别的……他们就会想杀了他。我觉得这是一个绝妙的梗。不过，珍，既然我们聊到这儿了，你觉得作为父母有什么挑战？我知道这个清单很长，因为我也有三个孩子。但做你所做的事——而且我们的工作其实并不，很多人都有非常忙碌的工作，无论你做的是什么。无论你是在办公室工作、在户外工作还是做别的什么。
What do you find challenging as a parent? And I know the list is long, because I have three kids as well. But doing what you do, and again, our jobs are not, lots of people have very busy jobs, no matter what it is you do. If you work in an office or you work outside or whatever it is you do.
但你觉得有哪些挑战？我们的工作本来就是一份很自私的工作，老实说。对。它真的，即便在最好的情况下，我们也总是：嗯，现在一切都得围着我转。我在拍戏，我得去睡觉，或者我不能去那儿因为我的剧组在拍这个，我的，你知道的。这就不是，生活不是这样的，孩子们的生活也不是这样的。如果有什么事情
But what are the challenges that you find? Our job is just a selfish job, honestly. Yeah. It's really, it's not, even in the best of circumstances, we're really, like, well, it's all about me right now. I'm in production and I've got to go to bed or I've got to, I can't be there because my production, this, my, you know, and it's like, that doesn't, that's not the way and the travel. And that's not the way kids' lives work. If something is happening
对他们来说正在发生，那就是对他们正在发生。而你却错过了。基本上就是这样。所以有太多的挑战，我是说，有太多的挑战，比如青少年以及他们必须吸收和经历的一切。你知道的，每当我去看我孩子们的学校，我在那里，我有三个孩子在三所学校。每当我去看他们，看到那种盘旋的能量、孩子们叽叽喳喳、争吵不休、来回拉扯、权衡什么更重要、为了争夺阶层而挣扎时，我就会想：哦天哪，太让人精疲力竭了。我简直不敢想象他们每天放学回家前都经历了些什么。
for them, it's happening for them. And you're missing it. And that's basically it. So there's so much, I mean, there's so much challenging, like teenagers and what they all have to absorb and go through. And you know, like when I go to my kids' schools and I'm there, I have three kids at three schools. And when I go and I see the energy swirling around and the kids chattering and arguing and back and forth and what's important and struggling for hierarchy, I just think, oh my gosh, it's so exhausting. I forget what they've been through by the time they come home every day.
对，没错。那你怎么处理社交媒体的事情？这个问题同样抛给所有人。但珍，你对孩子们接触社交媒体是怎么处理的？因为我觉得这挺具挑战性的。好吧，到目前为止。我这么说是因为这听起来好像我带着某种评判的意味。但其实并没有。只是到目前为止，我还没有，我的孩子不上社交媒体，比如传统的Instagram、TikTok那些东西。我并不完全清楚他们都在玩什么。所以，你知道的，我完全有可能搞错。对，有很多绕过限制的办法。有各种各样的绕过办法，
Right, yeah. What do you do about the social media stuff? This goes out again to everybody. But Jen, what do you do about the social media stuff with your kids? Because I find it challenging. Well, so far. And I say, because it feels like there's judgment
但他们不会去刷点赞，也不会把自己发到网上。而且我知道，你对大宝和小宝的规矩是很不一样的。所以别拿这个来框死我，但这算是我的一种目标吧。我只是对他们说：孩子们，给我拿出证据证明这东西对青少年的大脑有好处。只要拿给我看。然后有些人会说：好吧，我孩子真的，他们就是这么交流的，他们在Snapchat或者其他什么上面交流。到目前为止，我都设法避开了这些。我们会继续坚持下去，我和本在这件事上意见一致。我们会尽最大努力沿着这条路走下去。对，我们也在争取做到这一点，或者说尽量克制。这真罕见。完全不接触。我想回到，首先，
inherent in what I'm saying. And there isn't. It's just so far, I have not, I don't have kids on social media, like, traditional Instagram TikTok, all that stuff. I don't know totally everything they're on. So, you know know I could be totally wrong. Yeah there's some work around there. There are plenty of work
因为我常问的问题之一是关于戏剧的，我需要一个你经历过的糟糕的戏剧故事，比如某个最糟糕的、出了差错的经历，或者在片场发生过什么糟糕的事。主要是戏剧故事。他只是在核对检查清单。或者任何类型的个人悲剧。
arounds but they're not checking for likes and they're not posting themselves and I think you know you rules are very different for your first than they are for your third. So don't hold me to it, but that is kind of my goal. I just say to them, guys, show me the evidence that it's good for a teenage brain. Just show it to me. And then some people say, well, my kids really, that's how they converse, they converse over,
任何类型的个人经历、巨大的遗憾、尴尬的事情。不，我觉得，我觉得戏剧故事，戏剧故事出错或者搞笑的。片场遭受的精神创伤会很有共鸣。所以，我是说，当我跑步时，比如，基本上我的本能，我精力旺盛，所以我会冲上舞台，或者我跑，你知道的，就像我经常那样。
snap chatter, whatever. So far, I've been able to avoid it. And we'll just keep down that, and Ben and I are on the same page about it. We'll just keep down that road as best we can. Yeah, we're trying for the same thing or sort of a limited version. That's rare. Of at all. I want to go back to, first of all,
当时我在理查德·罗杰斯剧场和克莱因先生（凯文·克莱因饰）一起演《大鼻子情圣》（Cyrano）。那真是天堂般的体验，美妙极了。但我陷入了一个魔咒，每天晚上总有那么一刻我会摔倒。后台是一个巨大的楼梯，直通两层楼高，完全是露天的。而我当时会跑着出场，look, look, look, look, look, 跑得极快，太好玩了。
because one of my stock questions, the theater, I need a terrible theater story that you have, like a favorite horrible, something that went wrong, or a horrible set that something happened on a set. Mostly theater stories. He's just looking at check boxes. Or any kind of personal tragedy.
所以我跑啊跑啊跑，最后10个台阶，摔倒了，摔在手肘上，或者我在第五幕时摔倒，或者在谢幕时摔倒。我只要一开始摔，就再也稳不住身形了，人们会跟我说：嘿，我看了你在《大鼻子情圣》里的演出。天哪，你太棒了。你知道的，我就是你摔倒那天去的。感觉就像是，你知道的，你应该……
Any sort of person, big regret, something embarrassing. No, I like, I think theater stories, theater stories get go wrong or hysterical. On earth trauma would be super relatable. So, I mean, I run when I, like, I basically my instinct, I just have a lot of, and so I'd run on to stage, or I run, you know, like I just do.
你开始穿护具了吗？我应该穿的。你知道吗，就像特技替身从楼梯上摔下来时会说：嗯，我在假发底下塞了个粉扑。话说回来，你每次连滚带爬地摔到台下后，有没有憋出一句搞笑的台词？没有，因为当时太严肃了。
So I was doing Cirono at the Richard Rogers with Mr. Klein, Kevin Klein. It was heaven, it was wonderful. But I got into a spell where I fell at some point every night. And the backstage was this huge staircase that was like two stories straight down, fully exposed. And I would come like, look, look, look, look, look, like really fast, it was so fun.
你不能。你知道的，你只能。太严肃了。哦天哪。太严肃了。太严肃了。你是新手。我想了解的是，珍，我很高兴你提到凯文·克莱因。
So I go, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, and the last 10 steps, go, go, go, go, on the elbow, or I would fall in the fifth act, or I'd fall at the curtain call. I just, once I started, I couldn't get my feet back under me, and people would say to me, hey, I saw you in Sierra. Oh, man, you were amazing. You know, I was there the night you fell. And it felt like, you know, you should've.
他是那种我一直很钦佩并且觉得非常伟大的人。那是怎么回事？我从来没跟他走近过。而且我，我觉得我们大家大概都没跟他走近过。你们有谁在外面见过他吗？从没有。一次也没有。
Did you start start padding up? I should have. You know when like, when stunt doubles take a stair fall and they're like, well, I put a powder puff under my wig. Now, did you end up coming up with a funny line at the bottom of your tuck and roll every night? No, because it was so serious.
我在纽约住了20年，一次都没见过他。他住在上东区很靠北的地方。他依然，他娶了菲比……凯特，他们确实是。对，对。他们确实是。
You can't. You know, you just have to. It's so serious. Oh my god. It's serious. You're a no- know, you just have to do it. It's so serious. Oh my God. It's serious. It's serious. You're a no-yous. I want to know about, Jen, I love you mentioned Kevin Klein.
他们就像是他们那个街区的国王和王后。我记得他有一部即将在苹果（Apple）上线的大制作剧集，是在伦敦拍摄的。总之，他是最有文化素养的人。他是那种总是沉浸在艺术中的人。他总是在读书。他的后口袋里总揣着剧本或其他什么东西。他总是沉浸在诗歌中并将其作为参考，这让人有点应接不暇。
He's one of those guys that I've always admired and think is so great. What was that? I've never come close to the guy. And I'm just, I don't think any of us have. Have you guys ever seen him out? Never. Not once.
对，你得绕着演出走。他当然是了。等等，他可是我的偶像！所以等等，珍，凭你所做的一切，你所取得的成就，有没有那么一个角色、一件事或什么东西，让你觉得：你知道吗？我一直想要空白（某某角色/目标），但我从来没得到它。
And I lived in New York for 20 years. I've never saw him. He lives way up on the upper east side. He's still, he's married to Phoebe. I've seen him out. Never. Not once. And I lived in New York for 20 years. I've never saw him. He lives way up on the upper east side. He's still, he's married to Phoebe. Kate, they are. Yeah, yeah. They are.
我依然想要它。这有点像，伙计们，你知道的，我是这个播客的朋友。我是，是的。当然。这不是重点，我是个听众。哦，伙计们，当你们请到那个西蒙·西蒙……勒邦（Le Bon）？杜兰杜兰乐队（Duran Duran）的勒邦？
They are, they're like king and queen of their neighborhood. He has a big show on Apple coming out, I think, that they shot in London. Anyway, he is the most literate. He's one of those people that is just always taking in art. He's always reading. He's always a play in his back pocket or something. He's always taking in poetry and using it as a reference and it makes you kind of panic.
那太酷了。是的，他真的很酷。他真的很酷。就像克里斯·法利（Chris Farley）在《周六夜现场》里的脱口秀那样。当你们请到时，我跑去看了。那太酷了。
Yeah, you gotta go around the show. Of course he is. No wait, he's my idol. So wait, Jen, with everything that you've done, everything that you've accomplished, is there something, is there a role or a thing or something, you're like, you know what? I've always wanted Blank, I've never gotten on it.
不，你知道吗，等我的孩子们上了大学，我一直觉得，除了恐慌之外，生活里有点盼头是健康的。所以，我想去纽约尝试成为，你知道的，总会有那种
I still want it. This was kind of, guys, you know, I'm a friend of the pot. I'm, yeah. Sure. This is not it, I'm a listener. Oh, guys, when you had that Simon Simon. Lebon? Lebon from Dreddredd.
音乐剧里的小妇人角色。你知道，那是我的梦想。等女孩们上了大学，就是时候去纽约尝试戏剧了。去演吧。对。到时候见。你想演什么？
That was cool. Yeah, he's very cool. He's very cool. Like Chris Farley, Senator Night Live talk show. And when you guys had, I went and ran on. That was cool.
我们一起去。你想演什么？我愿意。我们一起去。我们就从排练《情书》（Love Letters）开始。太棒了。对吧？肖恩，是这个问题吗？你为什么不把《单身公寓》（The Odd Couple）重新构想为一个女孩和一个男孩，而不是两个男人呢？
No, you know what, when my kids go to college, I keep, you know, I feel like it's healthy to have something you're looking forward to besides just panicking. So, I think I wanna go to New York and try to be, you know, there's always like
不，你知道吗，等我孩子们上大学了，我一直，你知道，我觉得除了恐慌之外，有点期盼的事情是健康的。所以，我想去纽约，试着去，你知道，总会有那种
a little lady and a musical. You know, that's my dream. When the girls go to college, it's time to go to New York and try theater. Do it. Yeah. I'll see you there. What do you wanna do?
音乐剧里的一个小老太太。你知道，那是我的梦想。等女孩们上大学了，就是去纽约尝试戏剧的时候了。去吧。好的。到时见。你想做什么？
I'll do it together. We'll you want to do? I'll do it. Let's do it together. We'll just do a little start with love letters. Great. Right? Sean, is that the question? Why don't you reimagine the odd couple as just a girl and a guy instead of a guy?
我们一起做。你想做什么？我来做。我们一起做吧。我们就从《情书》开始，好极了。对吧？肖恩，这就是问题所在？你为什么不把《生死恋》重新构想成一个女孩和一个男孩，而不是一个男人？
I'm not rap a poet. Rap a poet. We could call Pete Burke. He could direct us. Direct us in the odd couple. Could you imagine? It becomes War of the direct us. Direct us in the odd couple. Could you imagine? It becomes a war of the roses. We blow up the whole stage.
我不是说唱诗人。说唱诗人。我们可以找皮特·伯克。他可以指导我们。指导我们拍《妙对冤家》。你能想象吗？这会变成《玫瑰战争》的。指导我们。指导我们拍《妙对冤家》。你能想象吗？这会变成一场玫瑰战争。我们把整个舞台都炸了。
Totally. Yeah. So, when did you do the app, sorry, this switch? When did you do the Apple TV, your limited series that you produced, too? Uh, uh, uh, you're a go right now. I was in production. The last thing he told me, the last thing he told me out now on Apple TV, plus, it's out now. Yes, it is out right now I was in production. The last thing he told me. The last thing he told me out now on Apple TV Plus. It's out now.
完全是。对。那么，你什么时候拍的那个APP，抱歉，这个转变？你是什么时候拍Apple TV的那个你担任制片人的限定剧的？呃，呃，呃，你现在就要开始了。我当时在制作中。他告诉我的最后一件事，他告诉我的最后一件事现在在Apple TV上，plus，现在播出了。是的，它现在确实播出了，我当时在制作中。他告诉我的最后一件事。他告诉我的最后一件事现在在Apple TV Plus上播出了。现在播出了。
Yes, it is out right now. We shot it a year ago here in LA with a sometime in Austin and sometime in Sosolito. How'd you like Austin? I love Austin. Austin's just, what a beautiful city. It's so cool. I'm pretty cool. And then you have the, everyone's drawn to the lake and.
是的，它现在确实播出了。我们是一年前在这里洛杉矶拍摄的，其中有一段时间在奥斯丁，还有一段时间在索索利托。你觉得奥斯丁怎么样？我爱奥斯丁。奥斯丁简直是个美丽的城市。太酷了。我挺酷的。然后你会发现，每个人都被吸引到湖边去。
It's so nice. Sorry, I just got to say just because I keep Austin weird Anyway Getting paid by the Chamber of Commerce there people used to have those bumper stickers. I mean, I'm really dating myself as an old It was poor. They yeah, they still the bumper stickers are still a thing Yeah, good callback great job. I'm so old. Yeah, I'm such an old All my musicals. I'm just like realizing I'm old Jen do any of the kids want to want to go into this business Have you ever got a sense of it?
太棒了。抱歉，我只是想说，因为我一直让奥斯丁保持怪异，不管怎样，拿着那里的商会给的报酬，人们以前经常贴那种汽车贴纸。我是说，我真的暴露了自己的年龄，像个老头。太糟糕了。他们，对，他们还在，汽车贴纸现在依然流行。对，很好的梗，干得漂亮。我太老了。对，我真是个老头。我所有的音乐剧，我只是突然意识到我老了。詹，孩子们有没有想进入这个行业的？你有过这种感觉吗？
I think we may have one but I don't know if that child knows it yet So I'm not gonna and how do you feel about that? Will you be encouraging if and when the light shines on him or her? What about you, Jason? What are you gonna do? I know, I feel like Franny, Franny's starting to get interested in directing, which is really exciting to me.
我觉得我们可能有一个，但我不知道那个孩子现在知不知道。所以我不会……你对此有什么看法？如果当聚光灯照在他或她身上时，你会鼓励吗？你呢，杰森？你打算怎么做？我知道，我觉得弗兰妮，弗兰妮开始对导演感兴趣了，这让我真的很兴奋。
That's really great. So we're like watching movies together and talking about all that stuff, it's kind of like my dad and I were. I know, just like about a year ago, right? Are you a little bit of a Franny? Yeah, yeah, Franny's like, Maple dad and I were. I know, just like about a year ago, right? Are you a friend of the same thing? Maple, I think, is interested maybe in acting, but neither one is like, you know, frothing at the mouth, super passionate about it.
这真的很棒。所以我们就像是一起看电影，谈论所有这些事情，有点像我和我爸爸以前那样。我知道，就像大约一年前，对吧？你有点像弗兰妮吗？对，对，弗兰妮就像……枫糖爸爸和我以前那样。我知道，就像大约一年前，对吧？你是弗兰妮的同类吗？枫糖，我觉得，可能对表演感兴趣，但两个都不是那种，你知道的，垂涎三尺、超级热衷的人。
I'm not a big fan of kids going into this business only because you could spend all of that time studying for a career where if you're the best at it, you're guaranteed employment. You know, and this is not that. Any form of the arts part in the term, it's also objective. So I don't know, it's tough. It's a tough business to make a big deal. You can't certainly can't say no if they become adults. And that's, you know. Correct. Yeah, I'll be encouraging if they're overwhelmed with desire for it. But kids acting, little kids on set, I don't know. Well, that's the other weird part for me too, it's sort of heady where you try to train yourself
我不大赞成孩子们进入这个行业，仅仅是因为你可能会把所有时间都花在为一个职业的学习上，而在那个职业里，即使你是最好的，你也不能保证能获得就业机会。你知道的，但这并不是那样的。任何形式的艺术，请原谅这个词，它也是客观的。所以，我不知道，这很难。这是一个很难取得重大成就的行业。如果他们成年了，你当然不能说不。这就是，你知道的。没错。是的，如果他们对它有着不可遏制的渴望，我会鼓励他们。但是童星，片场的小孩子，我不知道。好吧，对我来说这也是另一个诡异的部分，这有点让人头脑发昏，当你正在学习了解自己是谁的时候，你却试图训练自己去扮演其他人。
to be other people at a time when you're learning who you are. Yeah. And it's kind of heady found. Yeah. It would kind of messed me up a little bit. Yeah. And never thought of that. It's very done a little bit later, I think.
是的。而且这有点让人摸不着头脑。是的。这确实有点把我搞糊涂了。是的。从来没想过这一点。我想，稍微晚一点再做会更好。
Do you feel like sometimes you're like, am I a werewolf? Am I a werewolf or something? Yeah, listen, when I don't shave, when I don't shave every other day, it just start to let my nails grow. Yeah. Yeah, and it just scraped away.
你有时会觉得自己像个狼人吗？我是一个狼人什么的吗？对，听着，当我不刮胡子的时候，当我每隔一天不刮胡子的时候，我的指甲就开始长长了。是的。对，然后它就被刮掉了。
Yeah, no, it is a little schizophrenic definitely But um, thanks for bringing it down. Yeah She also told so that we're going down the technotaro highlight reel She just told the story great story the other day. She went to a party a bunch of people she didn't know to take me to our highlight reel. She just told the great story of the other day. She went to a party of a bunch of people she didn't know. And she came out on the second story balcony and she just screamed downstairs to a bunch of party goers
好吧，不，这确实有点精神分裂的倾向，但是……谢谢你把话题引向这个。是的。她还讲了——所以我们要回顾科技塔罗牌的精彩片段——她前不久讲了一个故事，一个很棒的故事。她去参加了一个派对，里面有一堆她不认识的人，来记录我们的精彩片段。她刚讲了一个很棒的故事，前几天她去参加了一个全是她不认识的人的派对。她走到二楼的阳台上，冲着楼下一群派对参加者大喊
and she didn't know they didn't order. She just said, hey guys, sorry, excuse me. Hi, yeah, up here. I just want you guys to know I'm going to bed in like 10 minutes, okay? And then she just went back into the upstairs. Okay. And everybody's like looking at each other.
她甚至不认识他们，他们也没点餐。她只是说，嘿，伙计们，对不起，打扰一下。嗨，是的，上面这里。我只想让你们知道，我大概10分钟后就要去睡觉了，好吗？然后她就走回楼上去了。好吧。然后每个人都面面相觑。
She, she, her friend, was she in her friend? Who is she talking about? She and her friend were doing what they call party bits. And she agreed to go to this party into the, into this house of somebody she didn't know. And she would walk into the kitchen and just kind of like slap the wall and go like, Hey guy, they're like six people. Because, hey guys, I'm probably going to turn it in about 10 minutes. And they're all like, okay, by the way, such a fucking God, Sean, how fun is that?
她，她，她的朋友，她是在她的朋友……她在说谁？她和她的朋友在玩他们所谓的“派对小把戏”。她答应去参加这个派对，去一个她不认识的人的家里。她会走进厨房，然后拍一下墙，说：“嘿，伙计。”那儿大概有六个人。“嘿，伙计们，我大概10分钟后就要去睡了。”然后他们都说：“好吧，顺便说一句，太他妈绝了，肖恩，这多好玩啊？”
That is such a good bit. What are the other bits? I want to know where it goes. I want to do the thing when I want to drive around all the fancy neighborhoods in Los Angeles, like Beverly Hills and Bel Air and then like drive up to like cruise who were like gardening and something go, hey guys, you can knock off for the day. Yeah, and then drive and then just be like, you don't worry about, don't worry about the front guys. I talked to the guy, you guys are good to go and start wrapping cruise who are doing work.
这真是一个好把戏。还有什么其他的把戏？我想知道接下来会怎么样。我想做这样的事：我想开着车在洛杉矶所有的高档社区转悠，比如比佛利山庄和贝莱尔，然后把车开到那些正在搞园艺的园林工人旁边说：“嘿，伙计们，你们今天可以收工了。”是的，然后开车走人，然后就像是：“不用担心，前边的人不用担心。我已经跟那人打过招呼了，你们可以收工了。”开始催促正在干活的园林工人。
Is it you live there? Yeah, is it if I live there? That's a good party bet. Not bad. Jen, what's the rest of your day today? You're not working on something, are you? No, I'm not working on anything. No, what is my day? I'm going to... You worked out at 3 a.m. Yeah. I worked out this morning, and actually, I actually have a boxing session after this. Oh, see. You worked out all the time. I boxed it Pete's gym. Do you really? Is he still going in there? This is Pete Berg. He still goes in there. Mm-hmm. Who's Pete Berg? Peter Berg is a is an actor director,
就好像你住在那儿一样？是的，就好像我住在那儿一样？那是个不错的派对把戏。还不错。詹，你今天剩下的时间怎么安排？你不是在忙什么项目吧？不，我什么都没忙。不，我的一天是怎样的？我要去……你凌晨3点就去锻炼了。对。我今天早上锻炼了，事实上，我待会儿还有个拳击训练。哦，你看。你一直在锻炼。我在皮特的健身馆打拳。真的吗？他还在那儿练吗？这就是皮特·伯克。他还在那儿练。嗯。皮特·伯克是谁？彼得·伯克是一个演员兼导演，
director, director. Oh, Peter Berg. Yeah, I was like, um, and has been, uh, has been ripped to shreds for years. Yeah. As always an incredible. Yeah. You can really box. Yeah. Yeah. Can, right? I don't get it. You can really box. I box this morning and then my 14 year old just started boxing in a gym. I'd rather play rock and talk. I remember that. Yeah. Sean, what time are you working out today? And Viana.
导演，导演。哦，彼得·伯克。对，我想说，呃，而且多年来一直身材保持得非常完美。一直是个不可思议的人。你可以真的去打拳。对。对。可以，对吧？我不明白。你真的可以打拳。我今天早上打过拳了，然后我14岁的孩子刚在一个健身馆开始练拳。我宁愿玩摇滚并聊天。我记得那个。对。肖恩，你今天什么时候锻炼？还有维安娜。
Look around. Look around. Look around. We. Look around. So wait, today's Tuesday. You have a shirt tonight, yeah? No, our off Mondays and Tuesdays.
四处看看。四处看看。四处看看。我们。四处看看。等等，今天是星期二。你今晚有演出吧，对吗？不，我们周一和周二休息。
So do you have two on Saturday, two on Sunday? We, we, we, we're doing seven. We're doing seven, yeah. Gosh, that's nice. Yeah, it's really, really nice, yeah. Yeah, well, what, what's normal? Eight. And, and where's the eighth show on a, on a Tuesday night?
那你周六有两场，周日有两场吗？我们，我们，我们，我们演七场。我们演七场，对。天哪，那太好了。对，真的很棒，真的很棒，对。对，那么，正常是几场？八场。那第八场演出是在什么时候，在周二晚上吗？
Two, nine, two, nine. Yeah, it would, it would normally be tonight Tuesday, yeah. Yeah, but we don't, yeah. I guess it's really nice. It's really nice. It's really nice. Actually, she feels like you have a weekend. Jen, what are you in Jason? What are you in Jason? When you in Jason, do your show and Broadway when you guys moved to New York? Yeah. Let Jason get into the deal because you guys would be out four shows a week. Oh, I know. We're going
两点，九点，两点，九点。对，通常应该在今晚周二，对。对，但我们不，对。我想这真的很好。真的很好。真的很好。其实，感觉你就像拥有了一个周末。詹，你和杰森。你和杰森。当你们在百老汇演戏，你们搬到纽约时？对。让杰森加入进来，因为你们每周要演四场。哦，我知道。我们要
to do only Matt Nays. I heard, I don't know this truth, but I heard Dali Parton. Somebody came up to Dali Parton asked if they wanted she wanted to do some big musical camera, I don't know if they have it. And she said, sure, I'll do four shows a week. They're like, no, wouldn't you do, wouldn't you say yes to Dolly Parton doing? Yes, Dolly Parton. Go party and buy a ticket,
只演日场。我听说，我不知道这是不是真的，但听说多莉·帕顿。有人找到多莉·帕顿，问她是否想演某个大型音乐剧，我不知道他们有没有这个。她说，当然，我一周演四场。他们说，不，难道你不会对多莉·帕顿说“好”吗？是的，多莉·帕顿。去派对买张票，
even if it's four shows a week. Yeah. I would buy a ticket for the show. I don't go to just to have the ticket to go to Dolly. Yeah, I don't know what she is. Did you ever go to Dollywood? Is that West Virginia? No, it's in Tennessee.
哪怕一周只演四场。是的。我会为这个演出买票的。我不是为了买票去看多莉才去的。是的，我不知道她在哪儿。你去过多莉山（Dollywood）吗？那是西弗吉尼亚吗？不，在田纳西州。
It's in Tennessee. It is so great. All the rocks have Dolly music, playing Dolly's music, everywhere you go. Rocks of speakers. The rocks have speakers. It was the first time I'd ever seen that. I was like, the rocks are singing Dolly Parton.
在田纳西州。太棒了。所有的岩石都有多莉的音乐，到处播放着多莉的音乐，你走到哪儿都是。岩石上的扬声器。岩石上有扬声器。那是我第一次见到那样的情景。当时我想，岩石居然在唱多莉·帕顿的歌。
And I took my grandmother, Xemay, and I hoisted her up over a, like, a, a Mary go round horse. And I just, I can't believe I did it now, thinking back. Like, I'm so glad I didn't break that little lady. But Xemay was in heaven. All right. So after boxing today, where there's then, I would imagine you're going to pick up at least one of those kids. Well, yeah, I've gotta pick up some kids. I have this little company called Once Upon a Farm. Yes, yes. Yeah. So tell us what that's all about.
我带着我的祖母，泽梅，把她抱起来，放到旋转木马的马背上。现在回想起来，我简直不敢相信自己居然做过这种事。天哪，我真庆幸自己没有弄伤那个老太太。但泽梅简直置身于天堂一般。好勒。那么今天打完拳之后，接下来，我想象你至少要去接其中一个孩子。好吧，对，我要去接几个孩子。我有一家叫做“曾经的农场”（Once Upon a Farm）的小公司。对，对。对。所以给我们讲讲那是怎么回事吧。
Wait, I don't know. Tell me about that. I don't know about that. Oh, it's actually, it's awesome. It is, it's all super clean, super organic, kids, and babies food. And it is pureed and it's cold pressed, so it's not like...
等等，我不知道。跟我讲讲那个。我不知道那个。哦，其实，那太棒了。那是纯天然、全有机、专门给孩子和婴儿吃的食物。它是泥状的，而且是冷压的，所以它不像……
Garbage. Yeah, it's not garbage. If there's no sugar added, there's nothing added. It's just pure... I would eat all of that, but I would put the sugar in it. Yeah, sure. You would... You don't need it because it's all fresh
垃圾。对，它不是垃圾。没有添加糖，没有添加任何东西。它纯粹是……我会把那些都吃掉，不过我会往里面加糖。对，当然。你会……你不需要它，因为它全都是新鲜的
and it's not cooked down, so it has to be... He loves sweet and low, though. He just has sweet and low on everything. You could add a little sweet and low on everything. You put it in a blender, Sean. Sean put it in a blender, and then he't put it in a blender and then he dad, he'd add some Reese's peanut butter. What is it?
而且没有被煮烂，所以必须是……不过他喜欢低糖甜味剂。他什么都要加低糖甜味剂。你可以在任何东西里加一点低糖甜味剂。你把它放进搅拌机里，肖恩。肖恩把它放进搅拌机里，然后他没把它放进搅拌机里，然后他爸爸，他会加一些里斯花生酱。那是什么？
It's a sweeten a little, right? Oh, there's sweeten. Oh, that's sweet. Oh, that's good. Thanks. How are you good to see you? Sweeten a little. That's a great dick day for you.
是低糖甜味剂，对吧？哦，有甜味。哦，那是甜的。哦，那挺好。谢谢。你好吗，很高兴见到你。低糖甜味剂。对你来说真是个绝妙的日子。
All right, so you're gonna go and work out? So I have that stuff today. I have calls and stuff like that. All right, but wait, let's get, I want trying to get to the evening time and I want to know I like do I like asking this. What do you curl up and watch that you're a little bit embarrassed that you're watching? Yeah. Oh, well, not because it's a bad show, but just because I mean, I still watch side-felds pretty much all the time, but that's nothing to be embarrassed
好吧，所以你要去锻炼？我今天有那些事情。我有电话会议之类的事情。好吧，但是等等，让我们，我想进入晚上的时间，我想知道——我喜欢问这个。你蜷缩起来看什么节目时，会觉得自己看这个有点不好意思？对。哦，倒不是因为这是个烂节目，只是因为——我是说，我基本上一直在看《宋飞正传》，但那没什么好不好意思的
about. No, just that I've seen them all a thousand. But I'm watching Diplomat. You are. Cherry Russell. Yeah, you look very nice. Oh, I heard that's really good. You look very nice. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's on the Amazon.
的。不，只是我已经把它们看了成千上万遍了。不过我在看《外交官》。你在看。凯丽·拉塞尔。对，你看上去真不错。哦，我听说那部剧很好。你看上去真不错。对，对，对。那是在亚马逊上。
What's that on the Amazon? Netflix. It's on the Netflix. On the Netflix. Very nice. The kids and I are about to start jury duty. We just need to get someone in the house past AP exams and then we're gonna do a show.
那个是在亚马逊上吗？Netflix。在Netflix上。在Netflix上。非常不错。我和孩子们正准备开始看《陪审团义务》。我们只需要等家里的一位成员考完AP考试，然后我们就要看这个节目了。
I hear that's good. That's got, uh, jury duties as a show. Yeah, it's James. Marston. James Marston. James Marston, that's right. And it's really good.
我听说那部剧挺不错的。里面有，呃，《陪审团义务》是一部剧。对，是詹姆斯·马斯登。詹姆斯·马斯登。詹姆斯·马斯登，没错。而且真的很好。
It's the only one who knows what's going on and the rest all know. He's just playing himself as like a, he's playing a bratty actor. He was prepping for it. We shot party down together at the beginning of last actor. He was prepping for it. We shot party down together at the beginning of last year and he was getting ready for it. He was like, what am I going into? This is going to be a disaster and is it more is it ethically okay to be messing with this person?
他是唯一知道是怎么回事的人，而其他人全都知道。他扮演的是他自己，就像是一个，他扮演一个被宠坏的演员。他一直在为这个做准备。我们在去年年初一起拍了《派对动物》，他当时在为这个做准备。他说，我这是要进什么地方啊？这会是一场灾难，捉弄这个人是否在伦理上是可以接受的？
And there's one person who thinks he's just part of a documentary and has no idea that everyone else isn't yeah. They just think they're on is in. Yeah, what they say is really cool. They just think I'm jury duty. He thinks that they're making documentary about this particular trial. And he's the only person and everything else is made up. Oh, wow. Doesn't know. Yeah, it's pretty cool. It's so wide. And that's good for kids, kids and adults.
而且有一个人以为自己只是在参加一部纪录片，完全不知道其他人其实都不是。他们只是觉得自己是在参与。对，他们说的话真的很酷。他们只是以为我是去履行陪审团义务。他以为他们在拍摄关于这次特定审判的纪录片。他是唯一不知情的人，而其他一切都是编造的。哦，哇。他不知道。对，这太酷了。太棒了。这对孩子和成年人来说都很好。
I mean, I don't know that it's appropriate for kids, but I feel like my kids have probably been exposed to plenty. Even Sam's watching the R-rated movies now? My 11-year-old is at times, sometimes. Yeah, I think from time to time. Yeah, it squeaks through there. But you know what? Now, do you curse in front of the kids?
我是说，我不知道它是否适合孩子们，但我觉得我的孩子们可能已经接触过很多东西了。甚至连山姆现在都在看R级电影吗？我的11岁孩子有时会看，偶尔吧。对，我觉得偶尔会看。对，会偷偷溜过去看。但你知道吗？现在，你在孩子面前说脏话吗？
I find that I'm starting to get very, very loose with all of that. Very loose, you see? Yeah. I don't. Yeah. On purpose? Or you just don't curse at all? Do you curse a lot? You don't seem like you Or purpose, or you just don't curse. Do you curse a lot?
我发现我开始对所有这些东西变得非常非常随意。非常随意，你看？是的。我没有。对。是故意的？还是你根本不说脏话？你经常说脏话吗？你看起来不像是会……是故意的，还是你根本不说脏话。你经常说脏话吗？
You don't seem like you do. I learned to curse. I didn't use to, but I can. And I do, I mean, maybe occasionally something slips out, but I really don't want them to curse in front of me, because I feel like you need to know that there are grown-ups you talk a certain way around, or that you behave a certain way around, and it might as well be me
你看起来不像是会这样的人。我学会了说脏话。我以前不会，但我现在会了。我确实会说，我的意思是，也许偶尔会脱口而出，但我真的不希望他们在我的面前说脏话，因为我觉得你需要知道有些成年人你在他们面前说话需要注意方式，或者你在他们面前行为需要注意分寸，而那个人最好是我。
So yeah, yeah, I really love that you're a good mom And you also have a busy day and we've taken a Time you have so many things to go do more important than talking to us But what an episode of our day with us. Um, but we're an after our day with a new. Yeah, my God. Big shot of sunshine. Yeah. Yeah. You know, thank you, Jen. So at least I didn't show you my bad hair. I can't let's say go back. Let's think about it. Any how can it be bad? It's long. Let's think about it. I don't know. We're gonna. Is that a strategy? Do you have a scrunchie on your wrist? Yeah, you got to be ready.
所以，是的，是的，我真的很喜欢你是一个好妈妈。而且你今天也很忙，我们占用了你很多时间，你有那么多事情要做，比跟我们聊天更重要，但能和我们一起度过我们的一天，真是一集节目。嗯，但我们的一天以一个崭新的……是的，天哪。一束巨大的阳光。是的。是的。你知道的，谢谢你，詹。所以至少我没有向你展示我糟糕的发型。我不行，让我们回去。让我们想想。怎么会糟糕呢？它很长。让我们想想。我不知道。我们要。那是策略吗？你手腕上戴着一个发圈吗？对，你得随时准备好。
I like to do a scrunchy. I'm always doing scrunchy bits. Oh, yeah, look at it. Watch him do a scrunchy bit. And he just, yeah, I think my hair. And then he's ready to go. And then ready to go. Thank you for that.
我喜欢用发圈。我一直在做发圈的把戏。哦，对，你看它。看他玩发圈的把戏。然后他，对，我觉得我的头发。然后他就准备好了。然后准备出发。谢谢你。
And then stretch out the ponytail. Yes, stretch it out. No, I was thinking, yeah, you do this. I'm always doing this with it, you know, like you're doing. He does. Hey, guys, um, did anybody see where I parked? Where I left my hair is right. I love Sean.
然后把马尾辫拉伸一下。是的，拉伸一下。不，我在想，对，你就是这样做的。我总是用它做这个，你知道的，就像你在做的那样。他确实这样。嘿，伙计们，呃，有人看到我把车停在哪儿了吗？我把头发留在那儿了。我爱肖恩。
I'll pick up somebody's purse at a party and just throw it over your shoulder. Guys, anybody anything from CVS? Yeah, I'm just running to CVS. And which way is out? Is that way? How do I get out of it? Also, anytime there's a candle anywhere on a table, whatever, Sean O'Lis grabs the candle, and then he, he'll shield the wind from the front of it.
我在派对上会拿起别人的钱包，然后直接把它挂在肩膀上。伙计们，有人要从CVS买什么吗？对，我正要去CVS。哪边是出口？是那边吗？我怎么出去？还有，任何地方只要桌子上有蜡烛什么的，肖恩·奥利斯就会抓住蜡烛，然后他会，他会用手挡住蜡烛正面的风。
She'll the wind. And I go guys this way, which way does that? The devil's been. The devil's been. Now, truly wasted your time. I learned so much. Thank you guys. Sorry, Jen.
挡住风。然后我说，伙计们，这边走，那边是哪儿？恶魔一直在。恶魔一直在。现在，真的浪费了你们的时间。我学到了很多。谢谢你们，伙计们。抱歉，詹。
No, thank you, Jennifer Garner. We love you. Thank you, Jennifer Garner. I love you, Jennifer. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you, Jennifer Garner. Love you, Jennifer. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Thank you. I love you. Last thing you told me on Apple Plus with Jennifer Garner, go and watch it immediately. Yeah. Do the right thing. Do the right thing. Bye. Bye, Jen. Guys, I feel like I got a, I got a, I got a personality shower. Yeah,
不，谢谢你，珍妮弗·加纳。我们爱你。谢谢你，珍妮弗·加纳。我爱你，珍妮弗。我爱你。谢谢。我爱你。谢谢。我爱你。谢谢你，珍妮弗·加纳。爱你，珍妮弗。我爱你。谢谢。我爱你。谢谢。我爱你。Apple Plus上的《你告诉我的最后一件事》，主演珍妮弗·加纳，立刻去看。对。做正确的事。做正确的事。再见。再见，詹。伙计们，我觉得我经历了一场，经历了一场，经历了一场人格洗礼。是的，
if I'm all clean, making to a flower who is just easy, easy, lovely, gorgeous, fun, funny talent. Right in the day. She made me feel better. Yeah. She made the day better. I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, I am, remember 13 going on 30, which we do even ask her about. Yes, 13 going on 30. That was the movie I was thinking about.
如果我都洗干净了，变成了一朵花，既随和、可爱、华丽、有趣、搞笑又有才华。点亮了这一天。她让我感觉好多了。是的。她让这一天变得更美好了。我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我演过《女孩梦三十》（13 Going on 30），我们甚至都没问过她。是的，《女孩梦三十》。那就是我脑子里想的那部电影。
She did it with Ruffalo, right? I think so, yeah. Is that right? Yeah, what about dresses? Wasn't there a bunch of dresses? Did she do that one? 19 dresses? 21 dresses?
她和马克·鲁法洛一起演的，对吧？我想是的，对。是这样吗？对，那裙子呢？不是有一堆裙子吗？她演过那个吗？《穿普拉达的女王》？《穿靴子的猫》？
I don't know. 17, 25 dresses. No, that was, remember she was in Dallas Buyers Club with, she's in Dallas Buyers Club. Oh my God, she won. 13 going on 30. I'm pretty sure it was.
我不知道。《倒数第二个男朋友》？不，那是，记得她演过《达拉斯买家俱乐部》吗，她演了《达拉斯买家俱乐部》。哦，天哪，她赢了。是《女孩梦三十》。我确信是这个。
Yes, a rough one. Listen, there doesn't want to hear us going down there. Her W I am W I just look it up. I was like, Oh my God. She's. No, she's done so much and she's always so. You're I always feel like she's one of those people. You're whatever she's in, whether it's in a movie or on TV or at some thing or even on a commercial,
是的，和鲁法洛。听着，没人想听我们在那儿……她的……我刚才查了一下。我想，天哪。她是。不，她拍过太多作品了，而且她总是那么……我觉得她一直是那种人。无论她演什么，无论是在电影里、电视上、某个活动中，甚至是在广告里，
you're all like, boy, I'm delighted to see Jen go. Yeah, absolutely. You know, I think one of America's sweethearts, absolutely. Even if she's asking me what's in my wallet, she's brightening up my commercial break. It's true. I know. Yeah, she does a bunch of those things. And it's so delightful.
你都会觉得：“天哪，看到詹真是太高兴了。”是的，绝对的。你知道，我认为她是美国的甜心之一，绝对是的。甚至当她问我钱包里有什么时，她也让我的广告时间变得明亮起来。确实如此。我懂。是的，她拍了很多这样的广告。而且真是太讨人喜欢了。
And that's almost, I don't mean that thing. That thing that everybody talks about. We like you look at her like, I don't want to sit front. I'm kind of sending. No, no, no, no. Yeah, you want it like, I want to talk to Jennifer Garner. I feel like my day would feel better. I just did. Sure. But you know, but but conversely, you know, it would be awesome is to see her in some gnarly dramatic part where she's just fucking rip in some part. You son of a bet. You just unleashing. What if she's got that?
这几乎是，我不是那个意思。就是每个人都在谈论的那种感觉。我们就像看着她，我不想坐在前面。我有点像在发信息。不，不，不，不。是的，你想的是，我想和珍妮弗·加纳谈谈。我觉得我这一天会感觉更好。我刚刚就这么做了。当然。但是你知道，但相反，你知道，如果能看到她出演某个艰难的戏剧角色，她能在其中大放异彩，那该有多棒。你这个混蛋。你简直是在彻底释放。如果她有那种……
She's not that bad. Oh, man. Why? Well, I just to see you like to see an actor go from, you know, zero to a hundred, right? I don't know. Absolutely. I don't know if everybody needs to do everything to do the thing, be good at the thing you're good at.
她没那么坏。哦，天哪。为什么？好吧，我只是想看到一个演员从零飙升到一百，对吧？我不知道。绝对的。我不知道是不是每个人都需要做所有的事情才能把擅长的事做好。
Well, put it this way, can you imagine her in a bad mood? No. Right? So wouldn't it be fun in a character, in a part, to see her just like, it'd be like so like shocking. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Like, if you were to see me in a part,
换句话说，你能想象她心情不好的样子吗？不能。对吧？所以在一个角色里，看到她那种表现，不是会很有趣吗？会让人觉得非常震惊。是的，肯定的。就像，如果你看到我扮演一个角色，
just being super nice and genuine to somebody. I wouldn't believe it. I wouldn't believe it for a second. But if I was doing a good job, it would be nice. I mean, they'd give you an Oscar. If you did that, you'd get a lifetime achievement award for that. Yeah, that's her test.
对某人超级友善和真诚。我根本不会相信。我一秒钟都不会相信。但如果我演得好，那倒也不错。我是说，他们会给你颁个奥斯卡。如果你那样做了，他们会为你颁发终身成就奖的。是的，那是她的考验。
Sure, believe it. Yeah, I believe. I was there. I obviously like, when she, when I see her have asked her to believe it. I was there. I was there, like, when she, when I see her. Here he comes. Oh boy. Here he comes.
当然，我相信。是的，我相信。我当时就在那儿。显然，就像，当她，当我看到她要求时，我相信。我当时就在那儿。我当时就在那儿，就像，当她，当我看到她……他来了。哦，天哪。他来了。
Sean, can I tell you something? I can tell you something. I can tell you something from a mile away. Because you know why I'm doing the roller-stores? It's a sensible player. Here comes the buy. Because the buy, if I buy a pull-up, can I buy a pull-up? Well, I never would.
肖恩，我能跟你说个事吗？我能跟你说个事吗？我老远就能跟你说个事。因为你知道我为什么要做这个卷发器吗？这是一个明智的把戏。他来推销了。因为这个推销，如果我买一个下拉式的，我可以买一个下拉式的吗？好吧，我永远不会。
Whenever I say something. I never, Scotty and I'd say, Fuffa. Oh. Oh. I know. Oh, wait a minute. Why don't we just, why don't we just go back start again? Why don't we just go back to saying goodbye?
每当我说话的时候。我和斯科蒂从来不说“Fuffa”。哦。哦。我知道。哦，等等。我们为什么不直接，为什么不直接回去从头开始？为什么我们不直接说，嘿，多棒的节目啊。回头见。从不发生。再见。我们为什么不那样做呢？所以，多棒的节目啊。回头见。从不发生。再见。我们为什么不那样做呢？所以，一直以来。所以当我看到珍妮弗朝我走来时，我总是想说，嗨，我从来不想说，哦，再见。
Why don't we just say, hey, what a great show. I'll see you guys later. Never happens. Bye. Why don't we do that? So, what a great show. I'll see you guys later. Never happens. Bye. Why don't we do that? So, so far, far, far, far. So when I see Jennifer coming towards me, I always want to say, hi, I never want to say, oh, bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见！啊！聪明！聪明！聪明！
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye! Ah! Smart! Smart! Smart!
聪明！聪明！SmartLess是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Granteri 100%有机手工打造的。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ Smart, less. 请在Amazon Music上收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery App上的Wondery Plus抢先收听无广告版。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Smart! Smart! SmartLess is 100% organic and artisnally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granteri. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less. on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明！聪明！SmartLess 是由罗布·阿姆茹尔夫、贝内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机手工制作的。[♪ 片尾曲播放 ♪] 可以在亚马逊音乐上收听 Smart Less，也可以通过在苹果播客或 Wondri 应用中订阅 Wondry Plus 来享受抢先收听和无广告体验。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。